Vladimir Putin is a formally recognized
the Eastern separatist regions of
Ukraine as independent states and has
ordered peacekeeping operations within
those regions which is tantamount to an
invasion of Ukraine which is kind of
a pointless statement because they
already invaded Crimea now this one
really gets a lot of people because of
course you have people we have people in
chat already saying that these Eastern
regions you know they've already
declared their independence though
initially even Russia didn't recognize
their independence so I don't understand
what that argument's all about only now
is Russia saying they recognize the
independence of these regions long story
short I'll just tell you my personal
perspective before we get you know I
want to make sure I get into all the
news and break down the facts for you
it's going to be a tough one because
there's propaganda there it's Warfare
we're in fourth and fifth generational
Warfare so you're going to be seeing
people who are going to try and sway you
and convince you of their evidence this
is the nature of war and you got to just
figure out what you think is true and
who you trust it's difficult but I have
friends who live in Ukraine and I've
regularly kept up with them and asked
them about what's going on and to put it
very simply for many of these people
they viewed it they view it as an
outright invasion of course there are
some people in the Eastern regions who
are sympathetic to Russia
but they don't you know based on the
people I know who have who have lived
there who know people from there they're
like nah Russia is just it's a pressure
campaign it's a tactic they use they
justify The Invasion by saying oh look
they voted for it then asked for help
now he can come in and then they do
I don't think the US will do anything
and I think this is happening because
Joe Biden is too weak to do anything
about it I think there's an opportunity
for Vladimir Putin he's taking it he
knows that Joe Biden is probably scared
about what his family's involvement with
marisma was and now what can they what
can really be done but it's also hard to
know for sure what's true because
obviously the corporate press the United
States is pro Wars pro-working B and
things will likely escalate now we got a
lot of articles that have popped up in
the past couple of weeks as well as
today uh talking about the fears that
this could escalate into a third world
war which probably just hyperbole or it
could be legitimate because China wants
to move in on Taiwan and this could be
the major distraction a battle a war in
Eastern Europe that gives China the
opportunity to move in and and take this
territory that they claim is Theirs to
begin with I love it when I talk about
this stuff immediately I get people
saying you're wrong Russia's not
invading they were voted in same thing
with Crimea and then when I talk about
China and Taiwan I get people commenting
and they're like Taiwan is part of China
what are you talking about Tim you're
making clickbait okay sure yeah welcome
to Warfare everybody's got an opinion
and everyone's got their 50 Cent armies
to post things that they're gonna say
one side is right one side is wrong the
corporate press the United States is
going to scream Russia's the evil force
of the world when it's the bigger
threats China is complicated we'll put
it mildly so we'll get into all of that
obviously there's a lot to talk about as
it pertains to global conflict and uh I
already see I already know people are
going to be alive but but Tim what about
Civil War oh don't worry over the
weekend there was an antifa shootout
with a local homeowner in Portland which
is
it's it's it's it's it's
um it's dark stuff a homeowner basically
told antifa your violent extremists get
get away from my home and then a
shootout started antifa's probably lying
about everything they've already lied
about a ton of it so it seems like
things are getting you know pretty
serious not to mention what's going on
in Canada with the phrasing of people's
bank accounts and a vote to basically
make the emergency Powers permanent
man
dark days indeed well joining us to
discuss all of this is Larry sharp do
you want to introduce yourself Larry I'm
Larry sharp and I know you might say to
yourself
um man that guy is handsome how could it
be smart but I happen to be both so
we're very lucky that I am both I'm
lucky I'm giving New York a second
chance at electing me as I'm running for
governor of New York under both the
libertarian line and the forward party
line and I hope also the unite line to
create an actual Coalition Against The
Establishment to make something happen
so I'm hoping that we can make that
happen that's what I'm doing and I'm
here thank you for having me yeah yeah
not to mention there's a whole bunch of
really interesting stuff to talk about
as it pertains to domestic policy taxes
a lot of stuff we were talking before
the show so we'll get into all that we
also got Chris Carr executive editor
timcast.com happy to be here and join
you guys forward party that's yang right
that is absolutely Andrew very cool yes
indeed yes I've made a coalition of uh
of all the misfit toys
that's very exciting Andrew Yang is one
of my faves how's it been working with
him
um good so far still new let's hope I
have some awesome stories to tell well I
want to show off this before I get
started someone sent me this in the mail
holy free nice cool I'm gonna be putting
it on the wall at some point thank you
so much uh that's it at Ian Crossland
big piece of wooden Beauty I love it uh
an iamian Crossland and I'll see you
soon indeed he is I'm also in the corner
pushing pushing buttons very excited to
have Larry he's a hilarious guy and he's
very sharp as well pardon my pun I
listen to his podcast on occasions
enjoyable you guys should check it out
before we get started though we have an
amazing sponsor biotrust's keto Elevate
C8 MCT oil powder if you're doing keto
trying to cut down the carbs or you want
to get some extra energy in your drinks
just take a scoop of this put it in Stir
It Up go to eat right and feelwell.com
and you can get access to I'm sorry you
can get 51 off of your supply of Keto
Elevate I dropped the bag on the
keyboard I was like oh no I don't turn
it off so you'll get 51 off your keto
Elevate I've actually been doing I was
doing keto for a while and but now I've
eased back into like a lower carb thing
just to kind of you know go easy on the
system but I love this stuff I put in my
coffee you know Ian's a big fan he puts
it in his coffee and they say when you
go to eat right and feelwell.com you get
a 60 day money back guarantee five grams
of the highly sought after mctc8 per
scoop free shipping on every order and
for every order today BioTrust donates a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kidhungry.org to date bio trust
has provided over 5 million million
meals to Hungry kids please help them
hit their goal of 6 million meals this
year you'll get free VIP live health and
fitness coaching from BioTrust team of
expert nutrition and health coaches for
life with every order and their free
e-report the top 14 ketogenic foods with
every order again go to
eatrightandfeelwell.com check that out
thank you very much to BioTrust don't
forget go to timcast.com become a member
to support our work all of our great
journalists people like Mr Chris Carr
who like their job uh would love it yeah
yeah I'd go as far to say love he would
very much appreciate if you became a
member to help him stay employed and
that's how that's how we operate we have
we have some sponsors we do some
sponsors in the show but membership is
what makes all of this possible so we
will have an exclusive members only
podcast up tonight around 11 or so p.m
so make sure you sign up you don't want
to miss that and don't forget to smash
the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and let's get into that first big story
out of axios this is crazy news
Putin orders Russian peacekeeping
operations in eastern Ukraine the latest
in a decree recognizing the independent
the independence of the donetsky
People's Republic and the lahance
People's Republic Putin ordered the
Russian military to conduct peacekeeping
operations in the occupied Ukrainian
territories the separatists don't hold
all the territory they claim so
recognition could swiftly evolve into
war unless Russia limits its operations
to the separatist held areas analysts
have also warned that Moscow could also
use any attacks on its troops in eastern
Ukraine real or fabricated as a pretext
for a broader War the separatists
declared independence in 2014 and have
waged a low-scale war against Ukrainian
forces since then with military backing
from Moscow the fighting has escalated
since Thursday with Kiev accusing
separatists of persistent shelling
across the line of contact I just want
to point out though um
I don't believe the corporate press
I don't know exactly what's going on the
U.S is typically run by establishment
political war mongers who will lie to
justify invading or triggering a war or
whatever
there was a lot of reporting that Russia
would seize Kiev and occupy and then
hunt down the supporters of the
president which is all just propaganda
BS
it's a complicated situation you know uh
I mentioned in the intro I have friends
down there and they view this as Russia
just building up an excuse to seize more
territory in eastern Ukraine because
they don't want Ukraine becoming a NATO
force but they don't want NATO on their
doorstep but I don't know what to
believe to be completely honest I
certainly don't believe Vladimir Putin
but am I supposed to believe Joe Biden
or is this all just some some dirty game
I'll say one sorry one one more quick
thing
as this was heating up we got reports
that at the Ukrainian Embassy they
started destroying computers and and
data well as as most of us know Joe
Biden was criminally involved at least I
should say in my opinion it was criminal
with uh barisma and his son getting was
83 000 per month being on the board of
directors for our Ukrainian Energy
company and then Joe Biden quid pro quo
told the president fire the prosecutor
the prosecutor was investing
investigating this company and then and
then as soon as he's out the guy who
founds it comes back it wasn't until
Donald Trump came in the guy fled the
country again so look I think it's
simple my view Joe Biden's panicking Joe
Biden was playing dirty with Ukraine
along with the rest of the Democrats
probably because they wanted they want
to set up you know an oil pipeline going
through Ukraine the the cutter turkey
pipeline
When Donald Trump was President all this
disappeared for four years there was
there was nothing really going on here
what happened then then Joe Biden comes
back and all of a sudden war is breaking
out it's awfully convenient
I feel like this is actually a good
thing I think in the reality what will
happen is they'll take over a certain
chunk of the country
Russians look good we look good because
we can say we saved Ukraine there'll be
some kind of negotiation the Norwegians
or the Swiss or someone who come in and
build some kind of Peace program they'll
call it the you know Kiev Accords or
something they'll call or something like
that they'll call Peace and it'll be
settled in a way that is acceptable for
everybody enough it's distraction
against the disaster the Russian economy
is it's distraction against the disaster
our economy is so it's good distraction
against all those things and it sets up
China for a negotiated deal on Taiwan so
it sets everything up in motion so I
think this is all great in the long run
for everybody they're all everyone's
gonna be happy meaning all the
establishment will be happy the
individual ukrainians they're going to
be screwed if we have the Senate troops
we're going to be screwed but the
establishment is going to be just fine
Putin is is getting a bunch of you know
pro-russian sea where Russia I know our
country's a disaster but isn't it great
to be Russian and the same thing over
here we're not talking about how bad our
economy is look at the news it's all
Ukraine yeah we're not about how bad
things are here it's all Ukraine so we
can all talk about that good distraction
life is good and we settle it without
fighting actually having a battle and
that sets up China to have some kind of
negotiation for Taiwan which would be a
it'll be a Hong Kong type negotiation
for Taiwan there are a bunch of these
articles that keep popping up talking
about uh what is this one we have uh
from the Sun here we go how Russian
invasion of Ukraine May trigger conflict
in all corners of the globe in
terrifying World War III expert warns
this one's from January they were there
were a couple today every every week you
get a handful of them and you know
obviously people are already saying the
title we used is is you know because I
mentioned the fears of it well the
challenge is do I do I act like these
articles based on my bias are all fake
and just say that no one's really scared
about you know if Russia moves into
eastern Ukraine will that be the
distraction China needs to move in on
Taiwan will China start using similar
tactics on Taiwan I I think that's a
legitimate concern and then and then if
we get spread stand across the board
what's Iran going to do what's going to
happen in Yemen with Saudi Arabia what
what's North Korea going to do so I
think there's a possibility there but I
do think it's fair to point out all
these big stories that are popping up
like Russia would occupy Kiev that's
insane yeah that's not going to happen
and also the U.S I really do not believe
maybe this will come back to bite me in
the ass I do not believe the U.S will
have active troops in eastern Ukraine or
in Ukraine fighting with Russians the
U.S is going to waggle its finger and I
think it's like you're saying Larry I'm
I'd be willing to bet that Joe Biden and
his people are sitting there and they're
like hey this this Russia stuff is
fantastic news for us absolutely yes our
approval is in the gutter everyone's mad
at us you've got protests they're going
to do a DC Convoy quick scream war in
practice Russia yes and we'll shake our
fists and see I'm strong I'm so strong
against these Russians Putin's a killer
he can do that very easily it's a smart
move for him to do that but in reality
if there are any U.S troops there and I
doubt there will be but if there are
it'll only be after this sure it is a
safe settlement like a North Korea South
Korea type thing right where we know the
odds of actual War are so slim then we
might put troops there maybe but I doubt
we will the Germans still want that
Russian energy right and the Germans run
Europe right the Germans couldn't win it
you know in military but they won it
economically so they still control
Europe and they want that Russian energy
so they're not going to fight a war over
that well actually I mean that's that's
the big thing isn't it was the cutter
turkey pipeline sure the Western NATO
the US they wanted to get I I bring it
up fairly often because it's significant
to everything that's going on
um and it's more than just this I mean
it's a you can get reductive and go
beyond why this pipeline mattered but uh
cutter was going to build the pipeline
going up through Syria and turkey Syria
said no Russia is an ally of ours we
won't do it then conveniently for the
U.S a civil war erupts in Syria and then
the U.S like well we gotta get rid of
Assad now oh it's funny how that guy was
blocking your pipeline and all of a
sudden you oppose him and you want to go
to war there Obama then basically funds
a lot of the really awful stuff directly
or indirectly that's happening down
there you get Syria collapsing then all
of a sudden it moves up into Ukraine
because that's where the gas prom
Russian Pipeline goes through it's about
a quarter I believe around a quarter of
energy going into Europe the West wants
to displace that compete and lower
prices Russia won't let them because
Russia's allied with Syria so now the
U.S they engage in conflict in Syria so
here I'll tell you the funny thing
we sit here and you've got the American
corporate press going like Russia is
invading Ukraine and uh and it's like
and what did we do with Syria that was
an ally of Russia and we were arming
Rebels we were calling for Bashar
al-assad to be removed saying he was all
these really awful things Russia's doing
the same thing in Ukraine right now this
is all part of the proxy war over energy
and some of us some of our weapons
actually killed Russians yeah right so
some of the Russians were killed by our
weapons world war three didn't break out
yeah because nobody wants world war
three right world war three is bad for
business yeah what they want is small
proxy wars small proxy wars really good
for business we learned that after World
War II right after a small proxy wars
great for business so we want lots of
small proxy wars throughout the world
that works very well for the military
industrial complex but I would say
any possibility of a world war three I
actually I'll put it this way some have
actually chatted with us and said that
World War III started a while back it's
just that we're not in that generation
of warfare anymore so now what we're
seeing is propaganda media manipulation
cyber warfare
and I think it's fair to say that um if
that is Modern Warfare we are in World
War Three well I would call it cold war
two let me if I could right we had Cold
War one after World War II which was
Soviet Union or Russia as number one
China's Union partner the Mad Mutual
show destruction was nuclear but the
battlefield was Espionage right that was
the battlefield during that one we won
that war right but of course we had an
advantage we had better Espionage we had
more money we had more nukes we were
ahead Cold War II started right after
because what America does well is when
the war lose the peace right so we lost
the peace and now we have world now we
have Cold War Two it's reversed China is
now senior partner Russia is now Junior
partner the Mad Mutual disruption is
cyber when it was nuclear and now we're
fighting in the markets and not in
Espionage so I think we're in Cold War
II and you're right we're losing
makes it feel a little more lukewarm
because in the Cold War citizens weren't
getting screwed over by stuff really
they were ducking covering in their
nine-year-olds thinking they were going
to protect him from a nuke right living
in Terror but the the shutting off the
bank accounts makes it feel kind of hot
it's not hot like a hot war will be when
bombs are dropping and the houses are
getting blown up maybe but I think maybe
in the future uh for we bring it up
often enough fourth and fifth
generational Warfare hot means something
else I'm afraid of the AI really if
we're talking about a hot world war
three would be like people are stuck in
the metaverse and then the AI starts
dropping Ultron dude yes but remember
that the the idea of capturing land is
nowhere near as valuable as capturing IP
right IP is the value now right land is
less valuable than it ever was compared
to World War II days right now look what
if the Chinese invaded and captured
California do they care only if the IP
is gone
if the IP is still there they win if the
IP shifts to Austin or something what'd
they get they've got a bunch of
expensive land they have to quell that
actually sucks yes that's all they got
Northern California is pretty good
Southern California is basically drought
written yes so if they don't get the IP
of Disney and of uh you know Silicon
Valley they don't get the IP what's the
value so they're trying to capture IP
which China is doing very well very very
well yeah Disney absolutely on board I
loved it when Disney plus thanked the uh
Shin Shang Security Forces for helping
them with their movie and it's like the
same security contractors that have you
know the uyghurs and concentration camps
but talk about IP capture there you go
it's it's a lot see this is the future
of War it's it's the control of
resources manipulation propaganda it's
getting LeBron James to come out and
defend China right it's getting Mark
Cuban and who was the other guy was it
Steve Steve Kerr was that his name yeah
and also uh John Cena right John Cena oh
yeah yeah yeah Steve Kerr is the Golden
State Warrior coach yeah yeah I'm pretty
sure he came out and he was like look we
got a lot of problems in America too
it's like oh dude come on man I'm sure
but yo I think what's happened I don't
even want to repeat the things that are
happening in in xinjiang I mean that's
just yeah nightmarish what's going on
with those people but then you got uh
what was her face that that woman on was
it Savannah Guthrie was that who did it
the Olympic opening ceremony oh yeah
Muslim so she was like see look at that
you know repudiation oh wow there's a
uyghur see everything's fine yeah CCP
propaganda brought to you by NBC this is
black how could I be racist yeah exactly
I think about World War II and how I you
would live my whole life like oh of
course I would support the invasion of
Nazi Germany and the you know the the
destruction of Nazi Germany or whatever
but like now today it's kind of like
we're looking at again do you support an
invasion do you support War do you
support putting your life on the line
and risking everything that we that we
have World War II most Americans didn't
remember we never declared war in
Germany
Germany declare warned us yeah we didn't
we didn't care about any of that stuff
it wasn't for we declared war on Japan
because Japan attacked us first correct
we didn't remember the speech the day
that will live in infamy yeah his words
were I want to declaration of war
against the Empire of Japan
did Hitler declared war on us
we didn't declare war on him technically
we were funding the British and the
French yes we could the French lent
least we were absolutely funding them
but declaration of war America wasn't
concerned about that remember all wars
begin for terrible reasons but they
always end for ethical reasons
right so they began because someone
bombed us or let's go get the the
Germans but it ends because Freedom
that's not how it started right so Wars
always end because of something amazing
but they begin because of garbage
I think well one didn't didn't begin to
end the the empires yeah but now it was
the war to end the empires yeah no it
was because people were being stupid in
in Europe that's why three cousins
couldn't get along with each other three
cousins couldn't like each other yeah
that's a good point like at what point
if you have a defensive pack with the
country do you renege on the defensive
pact or don't have one I'm not going in
yeah you got invaded like Ukraine you
have one
and we should not be in it
I I'm interested I'm interested in that
path yes wasn't that wasn't that Trump's
positioned as well yes well Trump was
better Trump wanted them to pay more
right I think he didn't go far enough oh
wow I would have removed ourselves out
of that NATO completely why are we in
NATO was was a pact to stop the Soviet
Union when the Soviet Union fell we
should have removed ourselves from NATO
all NATO has done a starter problems for
us I mean you know one thing I was
saying earlier is why should any
American care about what's happening in
the Eastern borders of Ukraine when our
Southern border is not a priority for
this president of the administration the
idea that they would be sending U.S
troops to Eastern Europe for some threat
of Russia but not be willing to secure
our own border as laughable well there's
two parts I want to bring up here I do
care
and we should care it doesn't mean we
should send young Marine Soldiers and
Sailors to die
right and there's and there it's not
black and white in my view I think we
can use the bully pulpit we can talk
about it we can try to make it better we
can get the American people to care we
can do that and assist but I don't want
to sit look I was a Marine and when I
was in Rain would I have left my legs in
the streets of Manhattan I'm in New
Yorker but I've done that of course I do
it today right if I thought the Chinese
were coming across the border or
something I'd leave my legs and shoots
in Manhattan today and I'm an old man
now and I would still do it but do I
want to send my kids who my kids are now
17 years old do I want to send my
children to go fight and die in Ukraine
no I don't but do I care of course I
care I don't want them to have trouble I
don't want them to be bombed I'm a human
being I have compassion I don't want
them to die but it doesn't mean I want
to send my children to die what I might
want to do is try to help them defend
themselves maybe I'm okay with that
right or talk about it or whatever the
case may be but people have the right to
fight their own Wars and to create their
own governments we had a civil war we
had a revolutionary war that's how we
started our country we won't let others
do it we were under the under the Yoke
of the British Empire for 100 years and
then we decided that the best way for us
to become independent was war the
Canadians thought nah we'll do it peace
both for the right answer each Nation
decides on its own then we had to have a
civil war the Canadians didn't have to
have one that's fine but for the right
answer apparently we are hanging out
with
um Stephen Marsh he wrote a book on
Civil War and he was mentioning read his
book Canada actually had some very
serious periods of instability it was 82
and 95. yep so you know it's not all
perfect no nation is yeah no nation is
if you've got to put people together
they're going to want to fight each
other it's how it works now hopefully we
can do it peacefully through politics
and through talking that's the best way
of doing it and that's what kind of
decided and that's good we didn't I got
a feeling in Ukraine that the Russian is
going to send peacekeepers in and then
Americans are going to be funding the
Rebels for the next 20 years again and
arming them and then the rebels are
going to become the villains when we're
done with it you know I just want to I
just want to say man uh Ukraine is
amazing beautiful country I got to hang
out in Kiev for for several months
amazing food
poverty wages good people beautiful
cities and absolutely horrible uh you
know what we're seeing here man it was
kind of crazy to see that this this
country what was it Luke was saying it
was like the Afghanistan of Europe I
went for a walk when I was in Kiev with
uh some co-workers and a friend and
we're gonna get we're going to get food
and you can see buildings that still
have bullet holes from Wow from World
War II I think it was or whatever that
when there was like artillery firing
that they just never repaired some of
these like inside it's fine but outside
you can see the scars of war and it's
kind of sad because these people are um
you know the people I met and hung out
with are just good hard-working people
who want to just do their thing but I
think sometimes they want to keep it
there on purpose right they don't want
you to forget or there are aspects of if
you go to Germany
um parts of where the Berlin Wall used
to be yeah they keep that stuff there so
you don't forget right they don't want
you to forget what happened so they will
so a lot of times people will purposely
say well I could fix that wall but no
you should should look and go oh right
war is bad let's not do that I love it
then when they start they start tearing
down the statues in the U.S yes and
they're saying like there's a meme where
it's like well what what about moving
the statues of uh of the of the Nazis in
Germany to museums oh wait there aren't
any because they destroyed all it's like
but as you mentioned there's parts of
the Berlin Wall there are still remnants
and you know look I I understand if
you've got a statue venerating can the
Confederacy or the or some of these
people like the clan or something okay I
get we don't want those statues up in
the middle of a park or something but
you put them in a museum if you're going
to remove them and you do it by vote you
do it by Community organization you say
how many of us agree on this the problem
is you get these lunatics who come in
with ropes and just rip them down
against that's anti-democratic that's
fascistic it's authoritarian as much as
I'd not a fan of the statues either I
think it's important if we don't put up
a plaque or have some remembrance of
what that was and why it was there
you're doomed to repeat your history I
like the idea of just auctioning them
all off
raise money for the state right which
you need money anyway right auction them
all off and then if you're some rich guy
who cares about the Heritage which is
often uncommon in Most states in this
world right the the rich guys will spend
the time they will buy it they'll move
and they'll put into their and they'll
donate to the museum but if you're some
guy who really hates some confederate
general and you want to tear a statue
down great getting the people together
buy the statue and have a ceremony in
your front lawn and destroy the damn
place look at this libertarian guy with
a free market solution you got it every
time guilty as charged let's talk about
let's let's move on what's happening in
the United States because we got this
this story
um
I don't know how to feel about this this
is uh let me read the title The Guardian
one dead and five wounded in Portland
shooting during protest in park
authorities describe confrontation in
Normandale Park between a homeowner and
participants in police violence protest
now
I don't know how to feel about it
because the conflict itself the the
fighting the shooting of course is just
outright bad regular people defying
antifa far leftists and saying get out
of my neighborhood is people waking up
to the crisis and refusing to to you
know refusing and rejecting it but it
leads to this and this is what's scary
because we don't we don't we don't want
Shooters on our streets you know the
people the people who um they post stuff
you know there's that joke app around
and find out and I'm like man you really
don't want to find out no matter who you
are you might wear the shirt you might
wear the hat we joking we have his joke
shirt that says step on snack and find
out the reality is I I assure you you
don't want to find out you know the
people who think that you know they
would get into a conflict and have a
good time of it you don't want to be
worried about your kids because you
might think you're tough you might think
you're brave but what about once your
kid who's at home and these people are
fighting in the streets so stories like
this man
I like the idea that regular people are
saying no to the far left I don't like
the idea that's resulting in this but I
feel like this may be inevitable so
here's the story just give you a quick
summary these anti-pafar leftists
they're doing their marches as they
normally do
they were armed reportedly according to
them and um some you know other
Witnesses pose but I don't trust them so
what they said was this guy comes up to
him screaming at him saying they're
terrorists and they're they're the cause
of all the violence and that if they go
near his house he will shoot them
and then abruptly open fired shooting uh
six people one of them died five are
injured and then they critically injured
him
they then go on to claim to the Press
they were unarmed yet this guy's
critically wounded they claim that he
just attacked them I don't believe any
of it if I were to make you know my
assessment based off what I know about
the far left extremists these antiva
types I'd say that you know look there's
a video of these guys pulling a guy out
of his truck and beating him
they were armed with rifles they were
blocking an intersection the guy was
honking at him said get out of the way
apparently the guy saw their guns showed
him that he was strapped they pointed
weapons at him he said tried he pulled
his gun pointed at them then they
grabbed him and started beating him how
much you want to bet something similar
happen this time the only thing is this
time the guy was like I ain't playing
any games and that woman is dead and
this guy might die as well so this kind
of stuff gets scary man but it I don't
know what you what your thoughts on the
uh thoughts on this are Larry because
you mentioned you read Stephen Marsh's
book on civil war where do you think
what do you think about this where do
you think this is all going if we don't
create someone who will step up and say
look what you just said right your your
thought process is exactly correct we
need people to think how you're thinking
this isn't I don't want to Ephron and
find out right I don't want to find out
and this is an example of someone who
did and it hurt everybody like nobody
won in this right a bunch of people went
to the hospital somebody died this is
lose lose someone's got to sit up and go
wait a minute okay I get you mad let's
talk this damn thing out and that's an
important piece and I hope we begin to
do that and the only way we do that is
by having someone like what you're
talking about say hey can we not fight
can we not do that if I was the mayor of
the town
and I've got antifa out or BLM out or
January 6 people whatever I got or I'm
uh Trudeau and I got truckers I don't
walk away I literally go there I
physically go there and say I hear you
you got an issue or a problem or concern
I'm going to give you a time and a place
we can talk about this and let's try to
make this happen
you start doing that more and more over
time this is the damage has been done
has been done for so long it doesn't it
isn't fixed by one guy doing one thing
it needs multiple people doing this
often this should be the norm we should
make protest anger when they do it we
respond with okay what's wrong versus I
will Hammer you
when you respond with I will Hammer you
they become desperate desperate people
do desperate things it's just human
nature what did uh Jefferson say when
I'm gonna get it wrong when peace Pro
protest is impossible violent revolution
is inevitable do they get that right
Kennedy I thought that was Jefferson
those who made a peaceful Revolution
impossible make violent revolution
inevitable thank you there we go I thank
you for doing it right yes yeah but I
don't know look up who said it because
yes you know we'll make sure but so I
want to make it possible Kennedy Kennedy
I want to go out of my way I want to
make it possible and Executives have to
do this it must be Mayors Governors
County Executives as a nation we don't
pay attention to congressmen or Senators
we don't we only pay attention to
Executives they have to be the ones
doing this but I I don't want to be I
don't want to Now bring up the the the
the pessimism here but when we were
talking with Stephen you know the point
I made he said something similar it's
like when will you and your country
realize you're tearing each other apart
you need to come together and I said to
him you know you're Canadian right and
he says yes I'm like you you like your
socialized health care and he said right
I said okay abolish It Go full private
free market and we got peace and he said
point taken right he's like I won't give
that up ever for anything and so for me
you know these these individuals for
instance these antiva types they are uh
consistently violent they are
consistently extreme and they are of the
the political faction that for instance
in California tried to repeal their
civil rights legislation from their own
Constitution
and they were they nearly succeeded in
doing so
when that comes up I just got to say I'm
sorry there's there's no circumstance in
which I negotiate with that person and
say well take away some of the Civil
Rights potential it's not going to
happen I felt like they didn't exist
until 2016 ntf I never even heard of it
until 2015. they they did uh they were
at Occupy Wall Street we just called it
you know the Black Block element it
seems like it's a response to Hillary
Clinton's DNC screwing over Bernie
Sanders and ripping any hope from that
party and then the Federal Reserve
printing insane amounts of money and
devaluing the currency these people have
no hope and now they're out there well
covert lockdown smashing stuff up
because they can finally be outside but
if we focus on the problems like that I
think that we can quell the violence and
calm people down you're right Ian what
happens with these people is their uh
despondent dejected they're angry they
feel there's no path forward and then
Along Comes a demagogue who says your
answer is communism they adopt it and
then we now have an expansive force of
people who have identified the problem
even they've identified a certain
thing as the problem that's not really
their problem they they uh unfortunately
will often side with the very
establishment that has caused them these
problems and led them down these this
path like you mentioned you know Hillary
Clinton and all that stuff yeah they
they'll they'll come out and be like we
hate the Democrats and then you'll get
someone like Contra points for instance
saying but you have to vote for Joe
Biden I'm like look my thought on Donald
Trump for 2020 was
I can choose the the Ivory Tower Elites
who gutted this country or the ball
rampaging through the Ivory Tower I'll
take the ball you know let them run
around and kick some stuff over for once
and otherwise what we go back to square
one yeah but you brought up a very valid
point here people always think you know
how how bad does it have to get
before people revolt there's there's no
answer that because people will stay in
horrible situations forever it's a it's
a phenomenon called learned helplessness
what they require is Hope was what you
just said and some demagogue gives hope
right and the best example I can give
you is Russia 1917. peasants forever 300
years no real revolts I mean here are
there some sporadic Rebels but no real
revolts for 300 years Here Comes Lenin
hey how about his communism thing and
all they knew was what can't be worse
than this right right sadly they were
wrong at once but they didn't know that
they had hope and the Hope was oh this
guy he's telling us something it's not
what we got now we know what we got Now
sucks and we've been sitting for 300
years okay let's try this communism
thing and it was basically the same
thing for them different name though
yeah um and nice nicer Flags so there
was some benefit I guess to it but
that's about it maybe some emotional
satisfaction there was some of that sure
absolutely so they you get that I think
it happens here too and if two sides are
fighting there has to be some hope and
that's the third party thing the reason
why I think and I am blatantly biased I
know I'm biased the libertarian party I
think the Liberty Movement is the answer
because it's the only movement where you
don't have to convert
you can be as liberal or as conservative
as you want to be just don't force your
view on others you want to have a
commune good happy commune over there
just make sure government isn't paying
for it we'll make government smaller do
your commune and you'll be fine you want
to have more free market we can have
that too we can have all of those things
if we change the environment right now
we can't change the environment the
reason why people get so angry is
because they realize this if the other
guy wins he or she will enforce their
will upon me
which means I must take less of two
evils
but uh
I mean some of these people are
authoritarians yes so but the but the
people aren't authoritarians I don't
know the leadership are what people want
is someone who will save them or make
them feel better with their lives better
solve their problems now you might say
to yourself but Larry they're voting for
you know
um authoritarians people don't want
freedom I don't I don't mean to be cruel
people want happiness
people want happiness not Freedom if
Freedom if they believe Freedom will get
them happiness they'll vote for Freedom
if they think some dictator will get
them happiness they'll vote for a
dictator they will vote for whatever
they believe will get them happiness our
job and Liberty Movement is to show them
that freedom is the answer so they vote
for it I completely agree but I do think
there are authoritarians who enjoy being
authoritarian sure awesome and and you
know uh man the story I told before I've
got a funny update on it and it's a good
example when I went to a sushi
restaurant with my girlfriend and we
walk in
it's very small the sushi restaurant is
maybe like 30 feet by 30 feet maybe
everyone's sitting down no one's wearing
a mask but there's a mask mandate so we
walk in oh yeah and the guy grabs a
couple menus and he goes you need to
wear masks and then I went oh nobody's
wearing any masks and he was like oh but
you have to wear it and I was like I
don't understand like nobody's wearing
masks while they're sitting down and
eating and I said okay the table was
literally about six seven feet in front
of us I was like we'll sit right there
and then we'll eat and he goes okay but
if you get up you have to wear a mask so
we had I'm like yeah no problem he ends
me and my girlfriend a mask and I say
okay
were literally three seconds from
sitting down when a person at the
counter goes put the mask on and I was
like I'm just gonna sit down literally
right here it's a couple and they were
like no put the mask on and I said are
you serious and all of the staff
simultaneously went yes here's the funny
thing about it we got an update
this mask mandate was in Frederick
County and it went into effect I believe
just uh after New Year's in January
now they've rescinded The Mask mandate
abruptly about a month later
why yeah oh well cases are down in a
month what you enact it then repeal it
like instantly the people there just do
as they're told they have no interest in
thinking about the problem thinking
about the policy or thinking about how
psychotic it was they were doing this
the only thing in their mind was whether
they like it or not was adhere to The
Authority or get out and so we did
so when you have I I feel like the
culture War and the crisis work we're
facing is you know types like antifa for
instance that are willing to go around
with rifles and tell people you can't
drive down this road anymore anymore
chanting who streets our streets forcing
people off of public property
they want to they want to use power
against other people I don't I'd kind of
like to mind my own business which is
why we're in the middle of nowhere with
a bunch of chickens yes get away from
everybody else leave me alone right so I
love the Liberty Movement stuff but I do
feel like you know the question that
came up with uh with Stephen was these
people won't they they want to rule over
you they want to and so if you take the
approach of if only you just left me
alone they'll say I will and then
they'll still try to impose their will
on you I suppose the the quote is when I
am weak I ask you for freedom because
that is according to your principles
when I am strong I deny you freedom
because that's according to mine and
that's what we fear with these types of
groups yeah what I would argue is I'm
sorry I'm just going to ask like what is
the libertarian approach to a mob that
is equally authoritarian and
unreasonable yep like what's the
approach to that so let me cover two
pieces if I could the first one is I
think what people want more than
anything this is universal is purpose
yeah so when I don't have purpose when I
feel without power when I feel like I
don't have anything to do and all of a
sudden the government says your purpose
is to make sure people wear marshmallows
on their heads you will go out of your
way to make sure people are wearing
marshmallows on their head you won't
care why you won't care what they're
doing just I have purpose and I have
power I'm gonna make sure you put
marshmallows in your head so I think
that's the real issue if we give them
other forms of purpose they'll go there
people want to feel useful people want
to feel important people want to feel
empowered people want purpose the
problem is we've shut people down for
two years sucked away their purpose for
two years and the only thing they have
is marching in the streets I mean there
weren't this many activists before covid
why they had to be at work at nine
o'clock in the morning that was their
purpose right well now you don't got to
go to work anymore what am I doing oh
Janie's yelling about antifa I don't
know let's go and they're doing it right
oh we get to have guns oh my God now
we're all powerful so again there are
leaders but the perfect storm was
shutting everything down and creating a
bunch of young men particularly but also
young women who had no purpose so they
will go do whatever is required my goal
is to create more purpose for more
people less of them will be in the
streets less of them will be trying to
impose their will because they'll have
other things to do that's the thing I'm
never gonna stop up the the
authoritarian
can I lessen them yes can I make their
recruitment a whole lot harder yes bad
people are bad people but they're
nothing without armies
so if I shut their recruitment down I
make everything better but how do you do
that right and so so I'll throw it back
to this this you know the story I was
telling right when you have people who
are in a I mean look Frederick Maryland
is not the biggest city in the country
it's moderately sized just it's about an
hour or so outside of DC
no one showed up to tell these people do
as you're told or else it was just all
of a sudden like an official
announcement went out everyone heard
about the official announcement so they
all put flyers in there in their doors
and said okay that's it we're just gonna
do it now because I Heard it Through the
Grapevine and that's that's not even
about recruiting that's just when the
state decrees it everyone just says okay
but what if all those people actually
had careers in jobs and families they
were working on right now they wouldn't
even have noticed well no I mean this is
a business right everyone's here working
at their job and all of a sudden they're
told by someone else oh they did a mask
mandate so sure you don't want to get in
trouble better do as you're told and
they all say okay but you just put the
point you don't want to get in trouble
yep right once you make the second piece
to his no opportunities
so when I have limited opportunities and
my only opportunity is just to sell
water I will do anything to sell water
because if I lose an opportunity I got
nothing
so if I think my only chance is really
this job that I have I will do whatever
it takes to keep this job if that means
you gotta yell at you I'm yelling at you
if I'm gonna throw you out physically
I'll do it because I want that job so
I'm saying the environment is the issue
what I don't want to do is punish the
player what I want to do is change the
game
right people tend to react to their
environments and the more we have the
right environment the less people whack
badly I feel like so that's what I want
so I'm starting to answer your question
how do you handle a mob right remember
in a mob the person who runs the mob is
the guy or gal who yells loudest
that's who controls the mob so you've
got to be over there and you've got to
be able to tell to that leader and get
them to either acquiesce or look weak or
stop or agree with you or in some way
shape or form so the group goes oh you
know what maybe I should be watching
Netflix instead of being here let me
look I want to point I want to tell you
a story real quick that proves your
points uh about whoever whoever controls
the mob the person who yells the loudest
this person who controls the mob and
it's it's it's it's literal it's
absolute literal so during Occupy Wall
Street there's this very funny moment
where everybody shows up to defend the
park rumors of a police raid were coming
everyone shows up in the early hours of
the morning and there's a huge there's
thousands there's a couple thousand
people there at zukati Park and occupy
some guys standing up on this ledge
because the park slopes downhill so
there's a part where you're like a five
foot ledge and he does the mic check mic
check and then everyone yells and he
goes uh should we uh maybe go March and
then everyone mutters and looks around
nothing happens then some woman goes
Mike Jack and then they all yell Mike
Checkers I say I say we go
merch and then it goes wow then I'll
just start following her that I was just
it was an amazing thing to watch I'm
like the guy asked if you wanted to do
it and no one knew when the lady just
screamed everyone just started marching
yes absolutely magical people just hey
if you yelled it I'll do it yes
absolutely the the issue is there's a
there's a book called The Book of five
rings by um Miyamoto Musashi yes one of
my favorite books excellent book on
sword fighting by the greatest sword
swordsman in Japan real person it's
actually mistranslated it's supposed to
be the book of five Scrolls but they
messed up in the ring you used to put
the scroll in so they must have been
translating it so it's actually the book
of five Scrolls and in the book he
mentions the idea of fighting multiple
enemies
right he talks about the idea of if you
have a lot of enemies in front of you
don't be afraid
drop the leader the rest will run that's
this entire piece now I take that not
literal I take that as control the
leader I I use the Lincoln analogy if I
make my enemy my friend haven't that
destroyed my enemy so I don't have to
kill the leader I have to make the
leader my friend I'm including my friend
the mob goes away the same thing or
you're just a leader the rest of this
person you're slave like what they did
with the Incans I'd rather not play
people though they took I think was the
Spanish took the Empire the emperor
hostile they basically kept him as like
a house servant for absolutely a month
or so and they controlled the Empire it
wasn't Montezuma was the Incan uh yeah
Emperor and they control the Incan
Empire after that and then they killed
him quietly yep uh but yeah that's how
you do it he takes the leader in battle
if you cut down the leader the troops
don't know what to do this is old battle
too so it's my new battle this is why
the Marine Corps always has rules in the
Marine Corps if you ever see the Marines
we have a blood Stripe Right we have the
own we are the only
um only service that has a red stripe in
our dress uniform that blood stripe
comes from the Battle of Chipotle Peck
is that right I think that's right
um is that right I'm not one of the
battles in the Mexican War I think that
was the right one where the officers
were killed and the non-commissioned
officers took over and still captured
the city anyway wow and from that only
e4s and above get that red blood stripe
the Marine Corps teaches you that when
the captain shot the hill still must be
taken which is so when leaders get
killed Marines still step up and do the
job this is what leadership is about
good leadership is about creating more
leaders which is why often Cults of
Personality fail because once that
person is gone there's no more leaders
there it's all gone if you create a
movement a real movement you create more
leaders around you so one guy drops the
rest pop up and the hill is still taken
right it's not that we don't need a
leader it's that we need lots of them
yes I always say the Liberty Movement
does not need a savior it needs hundreds
of Heroes
30 years so yeah I still remember my uh
my history it was an E4 that picked up
the no it was a bunch of
non-commissioned officers E4 and above
who basically picked up the issue and
kept going if you ever watch I had my
watch my uh my daughter and I watched
the movie um Full Metal Jacket if you
ever watched the part where they're
ready to attack the city of whey and as
they're moving into way City there's a
bunch of explosions the captain drops
the second the captain drops the stats
on gets up let's move and the staff
sergeant takes him and he's still moving
into the city anyway Band of Brothers
too man when they drop Behind Enemy
Lines the the captain goes down and the
Lieutenant's forced to take over all the
league users have that all of the units
have but mobs don't mobs are not Elite
so mobs don't have that trained elite
units have that Esprit de corps they
have that way of thinking mobs don't it
was Napoleon who said if you want to get
rid of a mob give them the whiff of
grape shot right fire around in a
marvelous person yeah my favorite movie
to quote of course the Patriot with Mel
Gibson there's that great scene where
he's talking with I think it's
Cornwallis and he says stop killing my
officers could you imagine what war
would be like people running about and
and then he has you know that's the
point but then I love he responds he was
like so long as your officers will are
killing women and children we will I
will order my men to fire on site which
is awesome I love that movie Mel Gibson
was amazing in it but that's the point
that was you know don't kill the
officers just kill the the lowly people
and then let the officers live because
we don't want disorganized Warfare it's
it's an insane thing to think that there
was a time where people were like we're
going to war and I want you dead but
we'll be gentlemanly about it because
you would you would capture the enemy
Duke and then you'd sell them back for
10 times the money you would make with a
peace deal or without beheading and then
their son becomes the Duke and hates you
there's no point so you're saying our
approach to antifa's all wrong we should
be capturing their leaders
they wouldn't be that valuable I think
that's what the law system has been
doing they've been incarcerating them
and bailing them out basically isn't
that a similar thing they're paying
themselves yeah actually yeah they
arrest them and then the antifa raises
money through crowdfunding to pay to get
him out of jail keeping this industry
rolling could you imagine if that's the
real reason there's not enough there's
not as many prosecutions with antifung
they get released a lot it's because
there's an industry around it high paid
lawyers politicians getting funding
donations crowdfunding websites they're
all like look if we convict them then we
stop getting the money from this economy
of activism and we and we have to pay to
incarcerate them on top of that that's
right we lose money I wish that was
unbelievable but it's not I wish that
was unbelievable but hey but but but I
mean what would you do I mean that's a
free market right
no no governments by default not a free
market Yeah by default once it's
government it's by default not a free
market right so no not at all how do you
balance that out libertarian Style with
with like the authority of governments
take having control of the authority of
government and being libertarian about
it that is one of the broadest questions
I've ever had I'll be a little more
specific how do you feel about like
public roads being owned by the
government yeah as a general rule that's
that's not a real thing in America like
Americans don't want to hear that so my
idea has always been instead you raise
money for infrastructure by leasing out
naming rights from that infrastructure
so an example in New York City is a
great example meaning so for example we
have we have dozens of bridges in New
York City they get mentioned hundreds of
times every day
um on you know the the reports the
traffic reports
um we see them on Google Maps they're in
uh TV shows all the time imagine instead
of it being the George Washington Bridge
it was the Netflix Bridge or the Pepsi
Bridge the Bud Light Bridge
yes you don't drink and drive they would
easily pass a 100 million dollars yeah
here how do I know that because I
brought this up in 2018 and there were
Bankers talking to me about what how
long is the lease what are we talking
about how long will it go because you
have to have it for at least 12 years at
least 10-year leaks because culture has
to also change right so just because I
want to name it the Pepsi bridge I mean
I still don't call the George Washington
Bridge so culture has to change to get
the Pepsi piece on there plus they also
control maintenance but we still own the
asset we own the asset a leasing right
leasing name me right to them you front
load the contract so if they screw up on
the maintenance we remove the contract
we get our money up front new contract
so now what happens you raise money you
end the tolls tolls in New York 15 to 18
bucks for one Bridge One Way yep you get
rid of those tolls now the regular
Working Poor and the middle class can
drive across the bridge truckers
independent truckers aren't getting
hammered because they pay per axle so
that now goes away and you don't have to
pay for the maintenance of the bridge
you take the cash you pay for the MTA
this is brilliant maybe we should
auction the name of freedom of stamp in
so it'll be like Netflix oh my gosh
you'd make podcast 18 million bucks for
the first year next Netflix yeah Netflix
yeah yes I don't know if any of these
corporations would want to be uh uh
associated with our free dominance so
we're building the new uh facility it's
like 50 acres in the middle of West
Virginia nice so uh yeah why don't we
just do that we just like hey if you
want you want to name it you got to pay
that's only it's only good for we'll do
a five year lease but that's what
government should be doing but it won't
here's the reason why government is
backward
in other words government says we're
doing something so government should pay
some crony some friend that I have to do
the work with taxpayer money should be
the opposite I'm giving you government
land or government you should pay me
why am I why because well if you pay me
I can't reward my friends with jobs and
remember government is always two things
a monopoly and a jobs program it's
always those two things if you take away
the jobs program then take away the
Monopoly government has very little
power
so they want to make sure that they're
always spending money to create jobs so
you become loyal to the government yep
right so that's what I always create an
office of this and office of that and
they put 40 million dollars towards the
10 million dollars towards it because
now my buddy and his son and daughter
all get jobs now and once you get your
population dependent on
government-controlled Health Care yeah
you never got to worry about losing
power ever again correct do you think in
like the age of uh fifth generational
Warfare meme Warfare and stuff that
naming roads and bridges corporate names
is dangerous why just because it
brainwashes people to think the
corporations are in control they already
think it and and then the other thing is
they already think it number one and in
many cases they are I mean Amazon is in
heavy control already but no matter what
the person who's actually control is the
person who can arrest you
that's the person who's actually in
control right whoever can arrest you is
actually in control so that's number one
but the second piece is there won't just
be one bridge that Amazon won't own all
the bridges well they don't own any of
them right the naming rights they won't
own the naming right so all the bridges
one of them being Amazon Bridge one will
be a Pepsi Bridge one will be a Netflix
bridge look if Amazon wants to get two
Bridges and drop 200 million dollars a
year they can get two Bridges it's fine
but there'll be a bunch of birds but
this is actually a really good idea
because check out this right when you're
when you're leaving New York you got a
couple different options for your break
yes right depending on where you're
going so uh when you're when you're
going north out of it what's that
Washington Bridge George Washington
Bridge what's what's another option
outside of the George Washington Bridge
in the same direction you can go to
Tappan Zee Bridge well it's actually
called the Mario Cuomo Bridge oh I still
call it because they we remember
something we are on Empire so we always
have to name our monuments over about
our royalty I would love to rename FDA
no hold on so yes so you've got you've
got the Cuomo bridge and the Washington
Bridge right yep now imagine because
this is an amazing idea imagine New York
leases them out and then Coke buys one
yep and Pepsi buys the other oh that'd
be awesome analytics but hold on then
one day you're driving and you hit a
pothole on the coke bridge and you post
on Twitter these potholes in the coke
which are trash I'm taking Pepsi Coke's
gonna be like we gotta fix this bridge
absolutely how much money to fix the
potholes and they'll fix it fast it will
yeah and cheaper incentive yeah you
could rename it the FDR what is it a
freeway the FDR the FDR Drive that would
be nice to rename absolutely it's kind
of scary to think though that you're
going to be like you're going to make a
right onto Netflix once you get to the
Pepsi Bridge yes you need to exit onto
the KFC Highway yes but the other
options the other option is horrible
infrastructure being paid for by poor
people right the advantage of this right
now is the left will always say I want
corporations to pay more me too let's
just do it voluntarily well they're
going to voluntarily pay for your
infrastructure you want I want you know
Netflix to pay for the MTA I'll get them
to do it they're happily do it companies
like Google and such have a 10 billion
dollar marketing budget that's just the
marketing budget per year 100 million
dollars easy day they don't care if you
think it would be okay to sell the name
of New York City to Google and just call
it Google no no no no no no no no Google
no terrible idea what's the difference
infrastructure is infrastructure once
you do the city that's Monopoly it's
just a name but it's the city it's one
city you've just made another Monopoly
we have enough monopolies I want to sell
things whereas lots of right lots of and
they can compete against each other lots
of they might want to buy two or three
of them good put tons not all of them
what if what if Google buys every
available infrastructure outbids
everybody and so it's like once you exit
at Google one you turn left on Google
three Google four is when you it's a
valid point and if that becomes a
problem Let's cross that bridge nice uh
right yes if if I hope that becomes a
problem I hope one company wants to
spend three billion dollars on and pay
for New York City's infrastructure let
that be a problem it's a pretty idea I
mean I mean truth be told uh like when
it came to setting up Freedom estan we
just called that I think Luke came up
with the name it's like you know like
Afghanistan or whatever Stan meaning
city and so he was like call it Freedom
stand or something freedom is standing I
said free dhama stand uh we could raise
money to expand our operation by
offering someone up the the the the
chance to to buy the naming rights for a
certain amount of time and then whenever
we're talking about it we would call it
like you know Joe's plum coming yes you
know headquarters or whatever 100 why
not look I was talking about the MTA
right the MTA is an old system right the
disadvantage of New York City is that
its system is very old the subway is
over 100 years old it takes forever to
fix anything to repair anything so I
want a brand new system it's too
expensive and it's a garbage system how
do you fix it okay at night for those
who don't know an MTA at night literally
every other train it's down over the
train so make it for the train to
freight train allow Freight to come into
the city well the first response I get
is well you can't have Freight coming to
the city the tracks aren't ready for
that I guess that means that FedEx and
Home Depot and Amazon have to build all
new tracks won't they and what we'll do
is every Hub they create they name their
own hubs so it's the Home Depot Hub it's
the so-and-so Hub it's not gonna be the
Moynihan station again named after our
Elites it'll be the Home Depot station
it'll be the so-and-so station they'll
get all the internet they'll rebuild the
entire system we'll get more freight
going to the city Less trucks on City
roads at night
they're happy we're happy and we get a
brand new system and we can lower the
cost to about a buck a ride have you
considered running for some kind of
political loss I have and here's the
worst part that plan's been on my
website for four years wow no one's
taken it I mean we talked about a great
idea one of the nightmares of New York
is is shipping yep it's so diff in New
York City particularly yes getting
getting Goods into a city so dense is
insane the roads are are shot correct
parking is ridiculous they've banned
like you can't non-commercial Vehicles
can't even Park in the in Manhattan
because it's just too congested correct
I like your plan this happens now now
literally if you want to be eco-friendly
the city isn't a place we have enough
hubs we could literally have walkers
people who are walking Goods people who
are backpacking you could use bikes
whatever you want like an Uber type of
thing you could make Uber whatever is
the right thing the point is as a
governor I don't have to make that
decision I change the environment and
then I got better players Larry Larry
solving problems for for regular working
people it doesn't work for the elites
because the problems keep them in power
but as long as I give them something
which if you notice I'm always giving
the elite something and it will create
new problems for them to worry correct I
I give the at least because if you try
to just fight the elite straight up
one-on-one you lose
correct so I bring them aboard I bring
them aboard and helping me out right
they they here's what I'm sure of Amazon
wants to advertise so does Google and
everyone else and they don't know how
they're throwing this stuff all over the
place they're figuring out how this
thing works I'm giving you away and I'll
talk about it on top of it as Governor
I'll talk about it dude A Fifth Avenue
is Amazon and then you had like Bed Bath
and Beyond I don't want to change the at
the streets the streets are in Manhattan
are all numbers I guess it helps you and
it's now to get to navigate so I don't
want to change streets right that's
going to want to all my policies are
always set up to help the Working Poor
in the middle class
but this is this is interesting and that
will hurt the Working Poor middle class
so I'm not okay with that so if if we're
talking about uh bringing Freight into
the city on the tracks on an existing
massive what you said something be
rebuilt Subway trucks that's going to
save these these companies insane
amounts of money yes so they're they
have a massive profit a profit incentive
for investing in this if they get access
to it yes and it's just their marketing
budget anyway they're not paying any
extra money no I mean like uh so I'm not
causing the Plenty extra money out of
their budget but they're putting more
money into into infrastructure but not
but I'm not talking about the naming
rights I'm talking about necessarily I'm
also I'm also talking about if you allow
the trains to come in and set up pubs
right they're going to say it's going to
cost us x per year if we invest 100
million dollars it'll drop it'll be x
minus y right we're gonna save money
over 10 years we're going to make more
and put more money in our pockets 100
they'll save money after the first year
that's right yeah so a little bit faster
why so so if there's an opportunity for
these corporations for the elites why
isn't the stuff getting done why would
you when the people in power just fight
each other
as long as long as we maintain this two
you know Left Right dichotomy there is
literally no need to fix anything we
just fight each other right if you look
at any I'm the I'm the Oddball here if
you look at anyone else running go to
that website and look for policy you
will find none what you will find is
other guy bad America other guy bad
America that's what you'll find and that
happened since believe it on Al Gore in
2001 all Consultants tell their their
people don't put detailed policy on your
website because then your enemies will
attack you on it let me put it on I
think the opposite third party has to I
don't get noticed without it I wanna I
wanna read uh for everybody a text
message I received today
proving your point
um you know I don't know if I should
read the guy's name should I he's
probably an office all right I'm not
gonna read his name but I got it he says
uh hi Tim he says hi Timothy this is
candidate for congress in New Jersey
second congressional district I tried
calling today to introduce myself I'm a
lifelong New Jersey and civil rights
attorney with a 27 year long career in
law enforcement and I'm running to for
Congress to replace turncoat Jeff Van
Drew there we go uh I'm trying to build
an early staff would love your money
it's not the first uh tax I've received
I also because it's it's tis the season
right
um let me see I got another one in here
somewhere here we go
uh let's see who is this one okay here
we go hi Tim it's candidate the dirt
road Democrat that will defeat the queen
of Q Anon Marjorie Taylor Green in
November I said you know what man I've
gotten a bunch of these texts from
Democrats and all of them are like I
hate this person so give me money yes
that's all of them that way what we
what's happened now again this is a left
for us invite Paradigm it's now a point
where my victory is you losing my
victory isn't me winning my victory is
you losing so your pain is my joy who
wins with that no no one no one this is
Gandhi's eye for an eye and we all go
blind this is not the way of doing
things it's got to be how do we fix
things that make that makes things
better I can't get past the other guy
bad if I don't have a solution my point
is if I can show someone that my way
will make their life better I have a
chance of them voting for me and I still
get it when I add idea when it came to
cannabis right and I said let's regulate
cannabis like onions
it's a plant ready like onions let
Farmers grow if they want to grow a
craft grow in New York state if you're
poor grow your medicine in your backyard
right if you have my my saying was if
you like your dealer keep your dealer
right because because you don't have to
get a special license for it right it's
a plant right so regular onions oh good
people still talk about that like I'll
be in I'll be in New York a car will
drive by roll the window down go loves
you up bring it with onions literally
that will still happen that's that's the
point I was talking about earlier with
it which is for every policy you want to
have a policy that is you know radical
enough for someone to notice it but
familiar enough for someone to accept so
regulate oh that's familiar like onions
that's weird because there really aren't
that many regulations on onions in New
York there are too many probably
probably like carrots or something but I
don't care you pick the vegetable
regular like a vegetable now oh it's
different it's a plan this is why I
really liked
um uh Andrew Yang and who I forget the
woman's name is Marion Williamson yes
Marianne Williamson yeah I really I
really felt bad for her but I really uh
it was quite endearing when she was on
the stage and she was like I don't want
to talk bad about people right you know
they were trying to ask her something
and she was like I don't want to have to
do this right and I was like I respect
that but man did she get roasted by The
Establishment corporate press they
called it the crystal woo-woo lady and
all that stuff and she's like I don't
own any crystals I don't understand
Andrew Yang you know I was a fan I'm not
that big of a fan right now he's okay I
give him a c minus I was at I had him at
an A plus before and it was because his
website was loaded with policy I was
like man he's got a policy for
everything I love it he's like hey I
actually thought about these things I
want to fix them yes but then I feel
like
um you know like Bernie Sanders like
many of these other you know politicians
they decide to play both the
establishment and walk into that they
play that game I think I think before I
think he tried that and it didn't work
and now he's out that's why he's out and
I think it's the right move and by the
way I apology may I promote for a second
oh of course larrysharp.com that is
Larry's shop with an e and the E stands
for or electable so you can check out
Lottery shop.com and I've got all my
policy there and it's most of it's been
there
for four years I've just added some more
recent policy because the state has
gotten even worse I've had the idea of a
New York a New York state currency
an idea of a a stipend a yearly stipend
that comes out of New York State I've
had all these different type of ideas
but what Yang agrees with completely and
me agree completely is third party is
the only way to save the country I don't
think it's the only way because I want
more more political parties more parties
but at least one right it is so hard and
some if you're a Democrat or Republican
you may not know this but your party
actively uses your money to sue to throw
people off the ballot they go out of
their way to get judges to remove your
choice so it can remove your voice
that's what they do they do not want a
functioning democracy they don't want
primaries they want to select the people
remember with gerrymandering the parties
pick the voters the voters don't pick
the parties
so the parties picked the photos with
gerrymandering to make their decisions
on who gets what controlled opposition
and then none and then those who are in
charge then the parties picked the
leaders so no voting in in the primary
and then Jerry Manning ensures they win
so they're appointing all of these
leaders and begging you for money if
it's a chance for someone's going to
lose most the people who are begging you
for money know already who's going to
win they just want you to give money to
keep raising money it's all a grift
that's what most of them are doing you
make a third or fourth party
gerrymandering is irrelevant
right you make a third of fourth party
Us Versus Them is relevant why is that
because if you during Mander for say
Republicans in one District right most
uh rural districts are gerrymander for
Republicans right most are so most City
ones are gerrymander for Democrats
generally speaking right there's obvious
exceptions but a general rule well now
there's a third party in there
how do I know
right parties if you do it right will be
specialized parties right so this part
is gonna be heavily about whatever
um healthcare for all this one's going
to be about free market cannabis right
there's gonna be a bunch of parties so
if I'm a republican but that was but I'm
a single issue voter on these things I'm
going to lose that Republican voter from
a Democrat but I'm a Singlish one of
those things I lose that voter it breaks
up them it breaks up the uh the
gerrymandering I think you're right
um and full disclosure I've donated to
the Ford party
um for that reason there needs to be yes
uh you know something something
different and uh
I I still think that one of the problems
is
I'm not a fan of the establishment
Republicans I like the more populist
libertarian type Republicans up in New
Hampshire the Libertarians they run as
Republicans and the fear though is it's
a it's our election system it's first
pass to the post voting you're right
people are going to say look man I get
it the Republicans but I will do
anything to stop the Democrats I agree
and that's why we all three parties
Unite
um the libertarian party and the third
party have what I call the Bro program
yes it is bro b-r-o-b easier ballot
access to let people on the ballot it
doesn't mean you have to vote for them
but let them be on the ballot to vote
are rank Choice voting if we don't make
ranked Choice wouldn't happen you are
correct you're right you've got to have
a ranked Choice voting to where you can
say I really like Larry sharp but if he
doesn't win I like this person so I
wrote very Larry shop first I really
like him because you're really good
looking so I pick him on a total that
makes no sense as if he's hot and then I
go to the next person who I think of
policy is good I think that's actually a
Trudeau won yes so if if I don't win I
still get my safety net right so that CR
that we need that and last is open
primaries
so that people can vote in different if
I'm not part of a party I can set aside
what matters to me so say I'm usually a
Democrat I'm usually a republican but in
this specific race nobody in my party
that it's running is worth anything so I
want to vote a Democrat this time I'm
gonna turn this time so I have a chance
of doing so in the primaries so ballot
access rank Choice voting open primaries
that will change the country I dig it
what do you think about the mises caucus
I'm on The Advisory Board oh well there
you go yeah I I'm I would be an
advisable of of any caucus before with
you
um and I've openly said that they're the
only ones who actually took me up on it
oh wow yes I offered it for when the
Prague calls you I offered for them they
didn't want me so the only ones want to
meet with them so I took it so I'm open
to all caucus is it caucuses
caucuses president Dave Smith press
secretary Michael malice who would be
the VP in that circumstance has he said
has anyone mentioned it no no
Smith sharp do they have to be an
American
[Laughter]
you just have to live I think in New
York you have to be a resident of New
York State I think five years that's
interesting you just move in from Saudi
Arabia and five years later be Governor
uh yeah I'm pretty sure that's the rules
to be you'd be over you'd be over 30
you'd be 30 years or older and I think a
resident it's five or seven I forgot one
or two but I've been a resident for many
decades so it doesn't matter to me but
just a certain number of uh years do you
think there would be value to letting
non-american citizens or people that
aren't born in the U.S run for a
president and VP at some stage in their
life
I don't know I mean I I understand why
they did it in the past because a lot of
people weren't born in America we had so
much immigration they were about people
coming over and royalty coming over and
taking over and making American royalty
in the 1700s made sense then I'm not
sure now to be forward to would it be
terrible for for you know someone like
uh you know an immigrant who's come over
and learned the American dream to become
president
I don't know I think Elon Musk
particularly I don't know like they can
never do it it just seems so wrong no I
I I I still agree with it but I think
the issue is it's a it's a safety
measure against people who don't
understand our culture our values our
principles unfortunately it doesn't seem
to be working too well because we had
Joe Biden in office sure but that's
because
there is a a um malignancy growing
within this country that opposes what
the United States is and always has been
and is seeking to supplant it and it's
been growing exponentially over the past
10 years
I'm hoping you can call this bro program
the program I don't know is that the
program
kind of cliche it might not it might
play worth running through focus groups
done so doing it a bit of a dad joke why
was stealing it and giving you exactly
no credit thank you that's the way it
should be yes The Challenge on the
immigration issue is that you know for
one we're seeing a massive influx of
non-citizens pouring into the country
yes these are people who see opportunity
but don't understand the opportunity and
so we have we have we have it's a very
interesting problem you know I've often
said I have infinitely more respect for
illegal immigrants who are risking life
and limb traveling through you know
Mexico to try and come to the United
States because as an America there is a
dream of opportunity I have more respect
for them than I do of the woke leftists
who are like America is inherently evil
and all of that stuff the problem is
they're both not representing or
understanding I mean certainly I think
one ideal is better than the other that
America is great is better than saying
America is bad
but we need people who understand what
it took to make sure the country was
great the freedoms Liberties that allow
people to prosper otherwise you end up
with people coming here and being like
look I don't care I got mine you end up
with people being born here saying I'm
not getting mine so I'll take it
and that's
a malignancy I think it's growing in
this country and it's displacing the
people who are like
um you know I won't forget the men who
died who you know made this land free or
whatever the line is right I'm not sure
that native born Americans are any more
or less
um patriotic to before I don't really
know if that's true I know a lot of
native on Americans who do nothing but
bad mouth America I know lots of people
who are immigrants who talk great about
America and the reverse I don't I don't
know if I could I'd like some data on
that if is there any difference I don't
actually know it's not I guess to answer
your question it's not a big deal to me
either way to before with you I don't
really know if it matters much I learned
a new appreciation for the United States
when I spent time in Peru when you see
the national police on every corner and
like just like wow if I slip up here the
feds are on me there's no local
protection in these countries traveling
is amazing I live in Japan for many
years how long uh four years I was
teaching English there oh cool so um I
live in Japan for four years I toured
China Philippines Korea
um I was uh I had to do some work in
London and Berlin Lynn and when you're
in those other cities in those countries
you do see a difference you you
understand what it is to be American do
you speak Japanese a little bit so
Japanese driver's license so have it on
me oh cool cool
it is literally like I don't know 30
years old or something 30 years old I
still keep it huh
Japanese driver's license yes look at
this guy yeah looking all young that was
many years ago what were some of the
biggest differences you noticed it maybe
off the top of your head yeah I remember
one time that something was happening I
forgot what it was it was probably in
the late 80s early 90s as I'm gonna
guess and we were talking about burning
the American flag
and one of the students asked me I said
Larry why do you guys care so much when
we when you burn the American flag like
no one in Japan cares you burned a
Japanese flight that's why no one burns
the Japanese flag because we don't care
it doesn't make the news nobody cares I
said because you don't understand
something in Japan you were United by so
many things and in this particularly in
the 90s for sure but even now still
speak the same language same religion
same school system right read the same
books watch the same TV eat the same
Foods they're very much connected on a
different level but when you come to
America we're not we don't have those
similarities we are linked by our
symbols we are linked by our ideology
that's how we're linked the flag means a
lot to us because the symbol of what
keeps us together we don't have the same
other things Japanese you don't require
a flag that's just a piece of claw to
them they know they're all together they
know they're all Japanese that's most
countries not all obviously but that's
many countries countries that are not as
homogeneous or who don't have that
connection culturally rely [ __ ] symbols
and I think that was also a part of me
to understand that idea that how you
know some symbols matter how our
president is one of the only
um leaders who was both the head of
state and head of government that gives
him so much power and how we look in
most countries when something goes wrong
they blame the leader right something
goes wrong oh something happened you're
a bad leader we do the opposite
something went wrong leaders save us
right so when 9 11 happened somebody
blamed Bush they all said Bush come save
us right if that had happened in Japan
that government Falls
wow I think that the symbols thing is is
very apt very accurate because I've
often brought up why you know I think
this country is so important we are a we
have a variety of different ethnic
backgrounds religions and the one thing
that we all have in common is that we're
Americans and that's why I really uh I
very much despise the the critical race
theorists and their ideologies that
segregate based on race want us all to
focus on races and and identities
because
you can't really tell I mean the issue
for me is obvious and I've brought it up
you know with the audience very often
but having someone decide for you what
you should be allowed to do based on
your race and then separating people I'm
like no no we're all Americans here and
that's that's that's the one thing we
all have that's our identity is American
because there are a lot of people who
are here or first second third
generation immigrant their their
identity is not I mean if you're if
you're the the grandchild of immigrants
you have a very short-lived American
tradition you probably don't know too
much about the old country maybe a
little bit from your grandparents what
if you're what if it's your great
grandparents you have American
traditions and so the one thing that
unites all of us is it's America we have
a flag we have a national anthem we have
the pledge all of those things and we
stand together for these ideas we have a
constitution unfortunately now
whether it's because of social media or
universities there is a a growing
conflict with a lot of people who don't
believe in the flag they hate it they
hate this country they think it's evil
they want to see it destroyed and
they're gaining more and more power I
think there's powerful political Elites
I think they can wield this this this
raucous faction and that it will give
them some kind of edge but they can't
control it I think there's two parts
that
kind of make that hard one of them is
fractured media write the fraction media
which I think in general is a good thing
but this is a bad side to the fraction
media now we're all watching you know
we're not all watching Walter Cronkite
tell us what's good we're watching
individuals tell us what we kind of get
right we're staying in those those areas
that's well that's a great thing for
Choice that's a great thing for Freedom
it's looking for information that
there's more benefit than there is
downside to this but one downside is
that but now that becomes the second
downside our politicians our system
doesn't support anybody
so what is that what I mean by that all
the problems that happen
Democrats are the party of bad ideas
Republicans of the party have no ideas
so no one has actually helped I
completely agree and when no one is
helped people go well who's gonna help
me people have problems now in a
Libertarian world
we support communities for communities
to help people that's what we should be
doing in our perfect world obviously
we're not there but we want to start to
create a world where communities help
people fall down people make mistakes
people get in trouble that's what
happens we're human beings and we want
to have a world where the community
stuff and go okay I got you right you
come out of prison Community should help
you you're an addict Community should
help you right that's that's the goal
for us to be there we don't do that we
create programs what programs do is they
service you they don't help you they
service you so they keep you where you
are forever so we all have jobs but
actual actual non-profits that are not
funded by the government
those actually help people how do you
know because they have a donor base you
don't give money to somebody unless they
show you a success story
so I'm incentivized if I'm not
government funded to give you a success
story see look I did something we helped
someone I'm incentivized to do that but
if I'm government funded I'm not I'm I'm
incentivized to check a box
I check the box I get my government
money now you might say wait a minute
Larry they're a non-profits who who are
terrible look at the most of them are
government funded which means what does
that mean they're not actually
non-profits they're just government
agencies that are non-unionized so the
government gets non-unized workers
that's what that actually is Second
Amendment yes what about it how do you
feel about it I am the only candidate
who is pro 2A in all of New York State
not even close the only one I was only
one in 2018 who actually had a plan to
end our SAFE Act and those those you may
not know the Safe Act in New York state
was enacted in 2013 after Sandy Hook
which by the way did not happen in New
York state
but it was to stop all the sandy hooks
that were happening in New York state
which was exactly uh none
there was no problem we created a safe
act but basically what it said was you
are about a million New Yorkers who
legally purchased your firearm now you
are violent felons
because if you have a firearm violation
in New York state by default it's
violent whether you do anything with
that firearm or not it may literally
plastic pieces that go on your farm
illegal it created a black market
ammunition a black market and Firearms
making law enforcement's job even harder
it made it made sure that people who
have a smaller stature can't get
accessories to be able to use Firearms
well and it made sure that veterans knew
that if they got reported that they
would lose their firearms so it made
veterans with PTSD and TBI issues not
report anymore
it created a secret State Police in that
now our medical personnel have to report
if there's any problem this actually
happened I think it was Rochester where
a guy comes in after car accident the
nurse says oh my God how are you feeling
he goes I feel so bad I want to die she
checked boxes suicidal state police came
back to his Firearms wow yes so that
kind of stuff happened from the safe act
it made it made New Yorkers feel
terrible about it and many of them have
left because of it so I was the only one
in 2018 who had a plan to actually end
it New York state is insanely anti-gun
and I mean insanely anti-gun to the
point where if you take your legally
purchased firearm and you follow every
TSA guideline it is unlocked I'm sorry
it's locked up and unloaded and you
follow every TSA guideline you bring
that firearm into New York City you are
going to Rikers Island this is that is
going to happen yes the most violent
jail in the country you are going there
whether you're a male or a female with
or without kids that's happened more
than once Luke was uh I think I think it
was Lucas on this lucrutkowski if we are
changed saying that uh there are stories
where people will be traveling through
correct New York and it's for like maybe
an international flight or somewhere yep
they'll have a legal gun it'll be an
illegal case locked no ammunition yep
semi-disma like you know magazine
removed or whatever yep they'll check it
in their legal State yep and that New
York City has Cops waiting knowing when
you have a gun and they wait for you to
put your hand on the bag and the moment
you do they walk up and arrest you for a
legal possession correct that's accurate
and in New York state loaded has a
different definition
loaded is ammunition in the vicinity of
the of the firearm what's vicinity means
thank you thank you yes
it means
I don't know there's a box there and a
firearm there that's loaded that's what
that means wow yes New York State's
insane we have the we have the stickers
gun laws
in the country so what I want to make is
simple laws simple just Universal
Transportation how about that any place
you go in New York State anywhere no
matter what the local gun laws are
doesn't matter if your firearm is locked
and unloaded you don't go to jail
that's not crazy that is that isn't a
law that people can accept you don't if
you bought your farm legally it's locked
and unload and change the definition of
loaded loaded means gonna sound crazy
bullets in the gun
that's loaded bullets are in the gun
that is loaded they're not in a gun it's
unloaded just do that now that means
other counties can have looser laws that
they want to no worries and many will
right lots of rural count as well was
much easier carrier laws and I'm happy
with that I wish there were more but New
York City is not going to be looser than
that right now it's not where New York
City is it's not where Rochester is most
of the Cities aren't that way so at
least get to that plus I'm doing
something else to get a permit in New
York state New York state is not a shall
issue State it's a May issue State and
it's I believe it's called um it's
called uh it's literally a May issue yep
but actually a no issue correct that's
accurate so I'm going to change it to a
shall issue if they don't issue your
permit in 90 days they have 90 day
waiting period they can check you out do
you whatever they want to do within 90
days if they don't say yes it's yes
and if they say yes and we by the way we
have an example of this already in New
York City with the Department of
buildings you have to build a New York
City or the real estate Moguls will
destroy you so our department of
buildings has a rule I think it's four
months I'm not sure if you don't get
approved within four months you're
approved or whatever I've had the time
period wow I want to follow the same
thing for firearm permits 90 days and if
they do disapprove you no worries they
must give you a reason and an appeals
process why not right now they do not
have to give you a reason or an appeals
process they just go I don't like you no
that is totally legal in New York state
why 90 days though because we already
have 90 days
so I want to again familiar enough but
radical enough all right we already
right now officially born 90 days but
what they do is they always say we don't
have enough people we don't have enough
bodies and we're we're a May issue
anyway so they usually in certain places
they'll take two years to get a permit
we need uh there's a there's a a Supreme
Court case coming I believe right yep um
did it already happen no it did okay so
so that's that's about May issue versus
shall issue right the the issue we're
going to have is new estate's gonna
fight it and they already are yeah right
but they're going to lose I I think yeah
I think we'll see so this is basically
um my understanding is the suit is some
dude tried to buy a gun and they uh
denied him right they said he needed a
valid reason because he said no I don't
now it's go now it's gone to the Supreme
Court correct and that's my entire point
right that should not be a thing if if a
county is going to deny you they have to
give you a reason why and you have to
have an appeals process let me let me
tell everybody you know look there are a
lot of people on The Establishment left
side they're anti-gun I I think they
don't know anything about guns for the
most part there's a lot of these people
who claim to like I served in the
Marines I know about guns and it's just
like then you hear them talk and they
don't right like one guy I think was
like an accountant and he has like a
Twitter account where he talks about I
was a marine and they made me lock my
gun in the locker and it's like dude
you're an account but um anyway here's a
lot of people to understand about
um Maryland and New Jersey as I was told
so when I was in New Jersey I was like I
would I'm gonna try and buy I want to
buy a gun because um you know we had an
issue someone tried breaking in the
house and stuff like that and I was told
New Jersey is a May issue state but it's
actually a no issue meaning any person
who applies for a concealed carry permit
because you can't open carry at all it's
got to be concealed uh they will just
deny you it'll never happen and then I
was told but for you Mr pool oh you'll
be fine they'll they will they will get
you through no problem why well you're
famous yes the the powerful the elites
correct the famous the politicians
people with money you don't gotta worry
your little pretty little face about it
I was told the same thing about Maryland
Maryland is very strict they say it's
you know it's it's a May issue but it's
actually a no issue
and they go oh but for you don't worry
about it so you get these politicians in
these states like in Chicago this was a
big big issue everybody gets pissed off
about politicians all have armed are
they're armed they have armed security
they get all that stuff and then take
your right to defend yourself away
we can't have it that way well I do the
work that further I want I want to allow
local people to be happy locally
and a lot of times you find a lot of
people in particularly in cities who
really don't are happy with only the
cops having guns
so I want to be easier on localization
meaning I want to have a a floor that is
just fair to all gun owners
and then each County can be can loosen
those as they see fit and then we move
towards looser and looser and why do we
do that because there's a cultural issue
that we have to deal with guns aren't a
logical issue
they're a cultural issue right people to
your point don't understand guns most
people in cities look at the safe I can
go well it's been keeping us safe how do
you know well it says safe in the name
I'm not joking I've heard that more than
once like that's a thing they don't know
what it's done they don't know what's in
it they have no idea they just go well
no guns because I don't want people to
be shot many of them are good people who
just don't know what guns don't know the
value of them just go I don't like guns
because scary
so we have to turn them and show them
that there are times when a firearm is a
very good idea an example I will often
give is something like let's say you're
a um let's say you're a small statured
woman and you have a large statute
boyfriend who has beaten you
and now he goes away to jail and now
he's out
and you'd like to have a farm to defect
yourself now I'm not saying you should
but maybe you want to again your choice
the Second Amendment is not a
requirement it is a right if you want to
you can if you don't want to please
don't ever use them if you don't want to
you can't
right you can't I remember the story
I'll give up uh Often by the way I don't
own a firearm very often I support
things that don't affect me I live in
New York City I can't own a firearm
realistically right so I don't own a
firearm in New York City um I support
family law uh reform I've never been
through the family law system so I
support cannabis I don't do any weed so
all that stuff but my point of being a
story I'll tell you when I was a teacher
there was a woman who was a complete
pacifist and I mean total pacifist and
of course someone said well what if you
were raped right of course that question
will come up and she was very forward
she goes no no if I was ripped I still
would never want to kill anybody never I
want to talk my way out of it and she
goes I was in that situation before and
I did and someone said well what if he
couldn't it's her word she said I'd
rather be raped she goes I'd rather deal
with that trauma than a trauma of taking
a life and I said Okay okay then I
stepped in I said okay but would you
stop someone else from pulling a Gun and
shooting a guy she said no wow I said
well good then we're good you live your
rules I'll live mine right I want to
shoot the guy but that's fine that's me
she doesn't I'm not here to judge her
I'm here to not enforce my rules on her
and don't let her enforce her rules on
me and we're good well so uh over at
freedomic stand we're actually
implementing a gun mandate you'll be
required to have proof of a gun proof
that you you own purchase and carry a
gun and it must be loaded got it so when
you're walking and you'll need to show
us you know clear the chamber and then
show us the magazine put it in and then
you can come in gotcha but it's if it
saves one life exactly then we have to
do it agreed yeah I agree we made these
stickers for uh timcast.com that looks
like the vaccine conference has proof of
gun and then some people were like is
this like a database and I'm like no no
it's like you literally write down on it
it's a joke right a gun like you that
you does not register with everybody
it's yours you keep it no one files it
my concern with guns in New York City
maybe you guys can talk me through this
is that what if like groups of kids or
young people all are armed and then they
get into a fight and it's like well he
provoked it bang bang and then bullets
go flying through a window you mean
what's happening right now times 10. why
would we buy 10 because the woman in the
house that gets a gun to defend herself
can't defend herself from a bullet that
went flying Eight houses down you just
said times ten my question was how do
you know it will be times more guns on
the street I would imagine that it's
you'd have more likely for people I'm
glad you said that you would imagine
yeah that's my this is my fear of why I
haven't gotten really behind this this
thing yet and I respect his fear and
that's why I'm saying I wouldn't force
that issue upon him because his fear is
a common one right I I get that
completely what I'm saying is if you
look at where where does all where does
all the increased massive increase in
violence come from only one thing not
guns Black Market
Black Market is what causes all the
extra violence it isn't extra guns on
the street that's not what it's about in
New York City last weekend I think was
seven people were stabbed
yeah does anyone know this no because
it's not guns seven people were stabbed
I need Common Sense knife control right
is that we're looking for let me black
market is what makes it you get people
out of the black market you will have
less you will have less people dying in
Black Market because of the coveted
lockdowns went not just the drugs went
to labor went to resources went to with
the products went to all types of things
Black Market went everywhere people were
worried about robbing Lumber uh trucks
that's how bad it was in the black
market and I'll make this point for you
too in uh a an armed Society is a polite
Society one of the reasons why these
these these shootouts happen is because
oftentimes these fights break out people
they know no one else is armed there's
no risk to them when they're breaking
the law with a with a weapon they know
no one else can have so it's kind of
like you've created a system in in a
city like New York or Chicago where
people who don't care to go to prison
because they have gangs in the prisons
they can they can operate there same as
any any other place I I know I've met a
lot of people who the attitude on the
sell side was always if Chicago was
always like I haven't gone to jail yet
so they assumed it was going to happen
so for them it was like you get your gun
and guess what here's the best part
ain't nobody else got them so if you get
mad at someone and you're in a fight and
you use it you don't got to worry about
anybody else but what do you think
happens if you're in a city where
everyone is armed okay now there's still
going to be violence violence happens
but now you're gonna have these guys
being like dude we're on we're in a city
block where there's a thousand people we
are going to get riddled with bullets we
are going to be surrounded by people
armed confronting us the problem right
now in Chicago is a guy that's a gun
they go strap and everyone runs away
that wouldn't happen if everybody was
armed nobody's going to pull out a gun
when everyone else is going to point one
back at you well let me give you some
data for you
people who are legal gun owners
statistically commit commit less crimes
it's a fact you can check anywhere you
want they commit less crime if you are a
legal gun owner statistically you will
commit less crime it's just minus the
crime of possession
even that because the possession isn't a
crime because you own it legally so
possession isn't the crime right because
you own it legally so by default you're
going to have less crime number one
number two the reason why there's so
much violence and what they'll shoot in
the streets is because it's worth it why
the black market
if it was if it was easy to shoot people
wouldn't people in the in the in the
states that have lacks gun laws be
shooting people all day long they're not
there's not a reason to do so in other
words if if I know that the reason why
the black market was so bad and they
need violence is there's no cops in
courts we have no cops and courts in the
black market right now if he buys
something from me and he doesn't pay me
I can sue him I can call the cops if he
steal something we're in a Black Market
I can't so what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
get Tim say get your firearm let's go
teach him a lesson and I'm gonna do it
in the middle of the day because I want
you to see it and and you know I want to
point something out um Austin Big City
Texas is now a constitutional carry
state why is that Chicago and New York
are the stories of violence yes why is
that Chicago has some of the highest
rates of gun violence or Baltimore
Texas and Florida you can own guns there
we're not seeing it I'll give you why
why Chicago's so bad Chicago's so bad
because the federal government's so bad
as a general rule what happens in any
black market is you create like anything
else one or two because you create a
Pepsi and a coke right a McDonald's in
the Burger King same thing in the black
market there's usually two gangs Crips
and bloods whatever right there's always
two gangs so when there's two gangs
there's only one border so you only have
violence when as a border Skirmish along
that one border so there's nothing much
violence but the federal government's
been so good they actually go in if it
and infiltrated all these gangs broken
them all up there's not two gangs now no
one trusts anybody not this 300 gangs
which makes 300 borders which makes 300
border clashes which increases the
violence it makes more than 300 it's
like 300 times 299 times 298. thank you
that's the number you're going to get
yes let me add this point too uh and
then we'll go to super chats so there
was recently a black lives matter
activist who was arrested for the
attempted assassination of a Democratic
candidate he walked into the office of
this candidate allegedly someone did
pulled out a Glock nine millimeter and
fired several shots and did not hit a
single person
he decided to use a handgun he clearly
didn't know how to use and people don't
understand because they watch movies yes
hitting someone with a handgun is not
easy even at close ranges
if this person was was not able to have
the weapon if he decided to go with a
knife instead you'd be we'd be dealing
with that we'd be dealing with an
assassination not an attempted
assassination he walked in they said how
can we help you he pulled the gun and he
fired and there's a lot of mistakes
people make when their uh first getting
started with handgun so they don't know
how to use one mistakes that I'm not
good with handgun at all so one of the
mistakes people make is that when
they're pulling the trigger they pull
their hand causing the barrel to point
in the wrong direction they think
they're pointing it but they squeeze and
they point to the side so all that
happened was the bullet grazed if that
guy had a knife or a machete and he
walked in and walked up with a guy and
then just pulled it out
knives can be way more dangerous in in
different circumstances it's the funny
thing when people make that joke
bringing a knife to a gunfight and it's
like uh depending on the Range the knife
is is more deadly yes MythBusters did
this I think it's within 21 yards a
knife is more deadly than a handgun
every Soldier has a knife at their
gunfights I mean that you gotta have a
knife on you at some point but I love
this range you're probably better off
using the knife I'm in a couple one
piece if I could and that is school
shootings to to Tim's point
if everyone knows there's no guns in
school that's when you go shoot the
school up right so when when schools are
defending themselves against school
shootings what started happening they
started shooting churches
right people are going to soft targets
the thing to remember with any type of
school shooting or mass killing like
this it is not well it's a murder it's
actually a public suicide right that's
what it really is at its core right as
you reduce it it's a public suicide the
person knows they're going to be
finished and they're going out in a
Blazer glory in some way shape or form
and where do they go to a soft target so
people said Larry how can you stop
school shootings in 2018 and what I said
was make a very simple rule if you are a
teacher or an administrator if you want
to carry and you're licensed to carry
you may that's it you don't have to
carry not required if you're a pacifist
please don't but you may people said no
you gotta have armed guards okay I'm
guard first although I'm going to runs
away but if I don't know who's carrying
I can't plan because I don't know who's
carrying if I can't plan it is a hard
target I won't pick that Target now that
is only a Band-Aid because the problem
is kids when they kill themselves but if
I just became out of schools I make the
schools a hard target so everyone's
correcting me
it's 21 feet ah not yards I misspoke
yeah yeah it's seven yards seven yards
uh 21 feet yeah
we could probably cover that quickly
into that yeah the guy from The
MythBusters these are not in-shaped guys
they did this thing where to censor on a
foam you know knife and then the other
guy had to Target him with a laser he'd
pull the gun out and click a laser and
then even this guy these these two guys
who are very much out of shape the one
guy was able to run 21 feet and poke him
you know with the sensor before the gun
could even be pulled out did you do a
lot of knife training in the military no
hardly any well we got to go super chats
though so we'll uh we'll take questions
there if you haven't already smash that
like button subscribe to the channel
share the show with your friends head
over to timcast.com we're going to have
a members only segment coming up around
11 or so p.m it's gonna be a lot of fun
we really appreciate your support but
let's read what people have to say
we got Chris Starkey says some real Wag
the Dog Vibes going on with Ukraine and
the us right now wow right on
Ray P says Viva fry over 43 000 watching
on Rumble House of common voting wow
amazing they sure did that's amazing
good good job Viva he's doing a great
job
all right let's see what we got
RJ Phoenix says if we were in the 80s
the CIA would be sending arms to
Canadian citizens
I don't know about Canada but point
taken point taken
Bill Hughes says armed Portland antifa
pick fight with violent biker game gang
then blamed police when things get
violent PJ media is that what they're
saying is that what happened
I don't know
Clayton Johnson says Canada needs a new
government honked for American truckers
locked down D.C war in Ukraine is an
easy way to destroy barisma records
that's what I'm worried about
they announced that with the threat of
war the the American Embassy in
Ukraine's are destroying computer
records I'm like why would they do that
they have all the time in the world they
can put them in a car and just drive
them to live or something yeah like and
they're in Kiev like oh they probably
they probably transfer the data and then
destroyed it and just told everyone they
destroyed it
I don't know man I don't I don't trust
this guy uh this this Biden guy
I don't trust him at all
right let's read some more let's get
some more super jets in here
Dylan whoa says Tim would you be
interested in getting someone on the
front lines in Ukraine or the conflict
areas for reporting I'm an infantry
veteran and emailed pitches if I could
provide this for timcast
maybe I don't know if we're quite at the
point where timcast.com can be funding
War correspondence to be completely
honest but we'd certainly love to we are
working on a plan for following the U.S
Freedom Convoy so we can have someone
there documenting it it's gonna be
expensive man you guys understand Dom
look
if we're talking about what is it what
is it a six day you know like four or
five day drive they're at least yeah so
you've got car rental how much you think
that's going to run it's like 300 right
now a fortune a small fortune food
expenses we're talking it might be like
10 to 15 000 just to hire someone to get
them the resources to do this it might
even be 20 to be fair because if we're
talking about their personal
compensation their food you need more
than one person you can't send one
person on their own we want to do this
this stuff can be expensive but you
don't got to worry about it I'm just
saying just keep in mind those kind of
prices for for this kind of reporting
because we're doing it and uh that's
what being a member makes happen so this
I'm super excited for this to be able to
get like you know dispatches every day
from the from the US Freedom convoys it
makes its way to DC it's gonna be more
insurance too more Insurance oh yeah
yeah more equipment sure yep
um we're talking about equipment that
cost thousands of dollars insurance for
the equipment fuel
food hotel stays
all that stuff I mean we can we can um
we can work on low budgets for sure but
uh there's a minimum man people people
want to be able to get paid to do their
jobs right
Garrett Savant says we are in a lukewarm
War
I actually agree with that it's not cold
it's not hot
that's why it sucks so bad it's like
it's not hot it's not cold it just sucks
I can't tell because that's the frog in
the pot if they change the temperature
slowly enough you don't realize it's
changing oh I like that analogy good
analogy so we won't know when it's a hot
War because it's going so slow that's
good I like that well you know the way I
often describe it is that um when we
when we read history it's condensed you
know we talk about the American
Revolution it took 20 years Boston Tea
Party in the Boston Massacre three years
apart you know these things happen in
Boston it's like yeah overall three
years man the speed of communications
was very slow but it could be that with
rapid Communications it's speeding up
dramatically so that seems to be
something
Stephen says Tim more guns more
ammunition please stock up everyone love
you guys telling the truth and exposing
the lies all hail the beanie thank you
very much we have a lot of guns and a
lot of ammo like I have an obscene
amount because I I was just like I don't
know I guess you know these guns are
cool so I just bought a whole bunch yeah
I was like going to the gun store and
he's like you have a five so I just
throw it on the pile and you know with
this big old pile it's massive
it's going to be a lot of fun
all right let's see we got here
I miss guns I used to work in Armory oh
yeah yes so I don't get to deal with
them anymore home Brian says Canada
Parliament just voted to accept
emergency power for Trudeau yes they did
yeah
I think when this guy said in the 80s or
the 90s the United States would be in
there is like I I had this thought last
night like at what point are we going to
step in and stop a fascist uh government
from becoming a dictatorship that's our
job that's the whole point of the United
States is we prevent that and for them
not to even say anything about what
Trudeau just did maybe I'm maybe I've
got the wrong perspective and I don't
have enough info but it feels like
they're gonna do that here now for these
truckers they're going to come down with
the hard boot they're prepared and throw
all these guys in solitary
that's terrifying I don't I don't see
the the trucker uh here in in us I don't
see that truck Convoy working really I
can't imagine I can't imagine that DC
will let that happen yeah I just think
somehow they're gonna stop him whether
it's a physical barrier put them in jail
take all their money somehow January 6th
January whatever I think they'll do
something I I can't imagine it happening
the cops in DC will will gas their own
their own residence if it means getting
rid of this when you make a surprise
attack in the military you don't repeat
the Endeavor the next day like they're
ready for you now right that's what this
feels like yes
yeah but the freedom Convoy don't don't
underestimate the U.S Convoy as well
like we can't just assume they're going
to be alike we've not thought about
anything yeah I don't want to be the no
don't guy no I think they're gonna
they're probably gonna be like
I'm willing to bet the freedom Convoy
has got plans for all the stuff and and
for the most part it's it's symbolic
protest non-violent peaceful uh
non-violent Civil Disobedience I'm sure
many of the truckers are like we're
gonna pull our trucks up the cops are
going to come and arrest and Tow and
we're going to make our point you know
what I mean
I I I don't think that uh uh these guys
are just like wow I didn't realize there
would be police who could arrest us I
think they get it I think they saw what
happened in Canada
but we'll see I I gotta be honest I'm
willing to bet these guys look these
truckers know they got strategy truck
drivers talk to each other they know
what's up
for all we know they're sitting back
with their feet up like y'all ain't seen
nothing yeah if they really wanted to
destroy the economy they could do it
subtly where you don't know they're
they're not hitting their mark on
accident every day I don't think the
truckers want to destroy I don't think
they want to destroy the economy they're
making a point with the protest that
happens to be detrimental to the economy
but that's not the focus is to disrupt
the economy the focus is to end the
mandates yeah but I think there's the
power right if they if they actually
were to somehow insinuate okay if you
stop this Convoy there's a whole bunch
of truckers going to stop working
tomorrow if the truckers stop working
this country's in trouble we do not have
an infrastructure that isn't Road based
our infrastructure is Road based in
every way shape and form so if the
truckers don't move stuff doesn't get
moved there's no option other than
trucks so if they decide we're out we're
gonna We're not gonna work for five days
whatever imagine if all of a sudden
FedEx UPS all those guys there's no
one-day shipping all of a sudden anymore
right for the next five days we can't
get stuff I mean that seriously affects
the country yeah that I think in my view
that's their their trump card all right
B Rizzle says left my legs in
Afghanistan for nothing I'd prefer it
I'd prefer it have been for something
worthwhile yes all good though I'm with
your brother yet ton Tavern
Tavern is where the Marine Corps was
started in 1775. remember 75 in tunnel
Tavern in Philadelphia Pennsylvania
that's why that that's to me I said 70
75 1775. wow so what was it like of
course Captain uh Samuels that right
Captain Samuels I believe was the
gentleman who started it in tan Tavern
what's the story there why did why did
he think they needed a new Naval Naval
Personnel know how to fire
cannons and they know how to sail they
don't know how to ship the ship fight
Marines were created to ship the ship
fight that's why we have the leather
neck because we used to cross over with
pistol and saber we'd fight ship the
ship and the saber was to to block the
the saber battle oh look at that also be
noticed the top of a Marine Corps uh hat
uh cover has a cross on it that was so
that Marine Corps snipers would know who
to shoot oh my God right they see the
cross don't shoot him oh wow that was
the purpose of the cross on top of that
up top everything in the Marine Corps
you see is tradition remember Naval
forces and Marines are naval forces are
based on tradition
they're always more conservative yes
they're always basically to this day I
still remember my sword manual I could
still do sword manual wow for my Marine
Corps so I still do it in ncos with the
learn sword manual which is not for
fighting it's for a parade all right Jay
scharzer says thanks for having on Larry
he's a pretty sharp guy as far as
jarheads go can't wait to see the impact
you make going forward semper five
brother December Five Semper Fi is the
Marine Corps motto it means uh always
faithful indeed December Fidelis cut
down to Semper Fi Sterling Wilson says
Larry sharp for president tell that tell
that brother to run yes
yes well there you go man one step at a
time he's running zero beat says
correction it was the House of Commons
not Parliament the House of Commons
there were ones who passed the uh the
emergency Powers that's amazing I loved
it because um we had when we had Stephen
Marsh here from you know he wrote that
book the next civil war he said well we
have martial law in Canada now they can
just freeze your bank account without a
court order and I'm like well you know
we agree that's a problem right he's not
a fan of the trucker Convoy but he
certainly when you get people who are
opposed to the trucker Convoy to a
certain degree I think I don't think
he's like a you know I don't think he's
I don't want to say he's like ardently
opposed to it he's probably just like I
don't like these guys you know but when
he comes out and he's like wow martial
law over this you know you got a
government problem do you remember the
movie Gandhi
Ben Kingsley yes I've never seen it but
yeah you one of the greatest movies ever
made great movie at one point the ghani
Gandhi wants to make a march on a salt
mine right which is run by the British
Empire they own with assault in India
because they're the Empire so they're
gonna do a march on the salt mine the
Brits want to stop him so they arrest
Gandhi will they rest ganipan away the
Indians March anyway my point about a
movement being stronger than the leader
right the Indians March anyway they're
they're all dressed in white in a line
and they March towards this thing and
there are soldiers there with sticks and
they beat them as they walk up get
beaten walk up get beaten walk up get
beaten and the women are grabbing them
and they're all bloody and that was a
time where a reporter says this is where
the West has lost
everything you just sat there and you
beat unarmed people over salt and I
think this might be the case in Canada
if we are so cruel against truckers this
may be that same moment where people go
they're just truckers yep they don't
have weapons and you're destroying their
entire livelihood that's why I'm hoping
that this is that that's why I'm telling
people non-violence for Disobedience yes
you you look at January 6 and they won't
shut up about the violence you look at
the truckers and they're like they're
violent racist and none of it sticks
doesn't stick because you got a bouncy
castle and little kids playing and
there's like little dogs and people are
just walking around smiling and shaking
hands what they're doing with these
convoys is they're basically saying this
is our statement of no confidence and
that's all they're not hurting anybody
and boy does the media try and lie but
it just doesn't stick because
if you don't have substance behind what
you're saying at least a little bit then
the people are just not willing to
listen to your to your BS you know so if
they're they I've seen these videos
where there's a guy banging a pot in a
pan and it's being shared by all these
like establishment you know activists
and journalists and they were like
trying to insinuate violence and I'm
like yo it's people arguing it happens
it happens outside my house and what is
this there's just the violence didn't
happen right they try and lie man
all right Mr Obvious says this guy is
too smart to be a politician today I
feel proud to call myself a Libertarian
oh nice yeah very cool I'm winning yeah
yes Morgan Dawson says the 82nd Airborne
sent troops to Poland weeks ago the MSM
says to help train but as an 82nd
veteran we aren't trained in that manner
you can fact check me by the 82nd
Airborne Facebook page so is that is
that too implied they're being sent
there to fight interesting yeah 82nd
everyone is not a training unit that's a
fighting it's elite unit wow is an elite
unit they're paratroopers they're not
there to train right they might in
theory they could send some other
non-commissioned officers over you know
to help train polls that might happen
but they send a unit over that's not a
training unit yeah he's he's right
okay let's see we got
uh what is this one about all right
let's we'll
Grant Shearer says world war three is
Nations versus ngos Battlefield is the
culture
maybe maybe
yeah
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Maga folk text
me up with no actual substance yeah I
get the same stuff all the time and left
this at two yep right the left is still
the the left is very smart what they're
very good at is getting people to be
afraid of trump so if Trump isn't
running now they call it trumpism
so it's Trump right or you know trumpism
and the right is always stop the culture
where they're all fighting culture wars
right the culture War thing drives me
crazy because that's how nothing gets
solved
right and the next thing is culture War
makes the other inhuman and when it
makes the other inhuman and a threat to
everything I can say or do whatever I
want and I'm now Justified but the real
challenge is
when you have two parent factions that
that had that completely they don't
speak the same language and the scary
the worst thing is
in the culture war in the U.S and in
Europe you know Canada uh Canada and the
UK we speak a similar enough language to
where we think we know what they're
saying but words mean different things
like racism means different things
Freedom left and right right yep free
speech
the the fundamental understandings of
the Constitution they don't mean the
same things either side
yeah so out of America you know I have
to change my language when I speak to a
more left to right audience if I'm
speaking to a more left audience I'll
use phrases like public assistance more
right right I'll use welfare the same
meaning but each one hears it
differently so you have to know your
audience and use different phrases
different words it's important because
then they'll hear you right and you want
to I want to be able to connect and get
people to see that I've got some
substance so if I'm using trigger words
shut them off so I've got to find the
right words to use depending upon the
audience I'm talking to yep there are
certain phrases and terms that signify
if someone is left or right culture War
I mean obviously asking asking pronouns
is a dead giveaway of where you are and
what you believe in a bunch of other
issues Absolutely I'll go even smaller
saying the Democrat Party versus
Democratic party yep if you are
right-leaning you say Democrat Party if
you're a left-lining is a Democratic
party even though the party's name is
democratic that's literally the name of
it correct so you can say someone is a
Democrat but the party is legally
identified as a democratic but you will
find most people who are right-leaning
to the Democrat Party yep most people
who are left I've had people get mad at
me for calling it The Democratic party
yes I'm like but that's its name yes we
don't call it like the Republicans or
like they're
all right boxy Brown says the blood
stripe story from the Battle of Chapel
tepec is wrong the red stripe was on the
uniform two years after Jackson left
office when Archibald Henderson returned
to dark blue coats returned when
Henderson returned it's two dark blue
coats faced red I don't know I'm not
sure where that comes from that should
be talking about um
that's fifth commandant
I think fifth or seventh comment I
forgot which comment that he was I think
he was coming he was at one point he was
calm down in Marine Corps I forgot which
one he was Nick but the if you you turn
the the Red Coats inside out they were
blue and then there was red as you can
see the red there that he may be meaning
that he turned his stuff inside out and
there was the the red you see the red
stripes inside they swap out the Red
Coats because we didn't have uniforms
we'd see the red coats and tournaments
that out all right no Nick Crow says I
was deployed to Ukraine for a year I
wish you could know the truth just no
ukrainians die every day on the border
and we should be supporting them
I don't know about uh um being there
personally On the Border um but I do
have Ukrainian friends and uh you know
talk to them about it but I guess it's
always difficult because just because
you're from there doesn't mean you know
the truth either you know it's very
different you could be deployed to the
Border it's very very different
okay let's see what we got here
rylo says hey Larry I think Lewis
Rossman of Rossman repair group
supported you Lewis is also a lobbyist I
think for right to repair legislation
can you make a comment on right to
repair yes um Lewis is a friend of mine
I was on a show he's out of Manhattan
um yes he's totally correct and he's
trying his best to do with right to
repair and right to repair is a very
tough issue right because what happens
is you now have a piece of property that
you purchased but the software that runs
the property
is now owned by somebody else
so then if you want to fix the thing
they go no no no you own it but you
can't fix it but I own it so how can I
not fix it right and this is a problem
so how do you fix that so actually a
very simple piece the business must
decide
am I leasing this piece of equipment or
do you own it period that's it do I own
it then I may repair it
am I leasing it then you must fix it if
it breaks
done deal you make a simple rule are you
leasing or are you purchasing either one
change your business model to either one
if I'm leasing this phone it's broken
fix it
I'm not leasing this phone I own it I
can fix it if I want to it's a very
simple fix so like one company can sell
it when the other one can lease it you
get to pick yes which is what's better
for you or maybe the same company could
have either either plan oh cool right a
leasing plan or a purchasing plan if I
purchase I can fix it I own this piece I
own it well I don't like it because
myself was on it then don't put your
software or lease the software then and
then you have to fix it
all right Reaper Nation says Larry if
you become governor will you push for
constitutional carry people said it all
the time and yes of course I want that
I'm being realistic though I live in a
state that believes by every poll you
can find that most New Yorkers want more
gun control not even even Upstate not
Upstate but again most of the population
is in the cities right people always say
it's New York City it is it's also
Rochester Syracuse Utica Buffalo all the
cities are blue they all hate guns and
they're all violent which is insane but
that's just what it is so I have to be
realistic I have to go baby steps to
constitutional carry what I'd like to
get there I would first step is ending
red flag laws second step is ending SAFE
Act
um third step is constitute carry we
have steps to get there yeah I think
people should understand man um for one
I I I'm too a absolute the Constitution
is Constitution I I certainly think
there there could be reasonable limits
like owning nuclear weapons this is the
one that got me in trouble all the all
the outlets started yelling at me
because I said had I think I think the
second amendment protects the right to
own nuclear weapons it says the right to
keep in bear arms it's not about guns
you're right it's not about guns and
back then privateers existed in corsairs
private individuals owned warships that
could flatten coastal cities and they
were hired by the crap by multiple
different kings and queens to do just
that
now you've got Halliburton and Lockheed
Martin and Raytheon and they certainly
own very powerful explosives and weapons
individuals can too if private
businesses can if they can make them all
that stuff now if you want to argue they
shouldn't be allowed to it's like oh
okay absolutely change change
Constitution I don't think you have to
there is an exception if you could
realistically argue
that owning a certain thing
is actually a direct threat to others
now that would be an argument I'm not
sure it's right but that could be an
argument for example let's say I want to
have I don't know chemical weapons in my
backyard right I someone could argue
yeah but that's a threat if anything
goes wrong lightning strikes that thing
you know if lightning strikes your your
ammo dump then your property is blown up
I'm sure but if lightning strikes your
chemical plant
then everyone gets you know chemical
weapons dropped on them for four miles
away so I think that's an argument you
could make an argument without having to
change the I disagree I disagree
um there's inherent risks to owning
anything you can own uh uh a car sure
it's full of gasoline absolutely and
they could have a leak and a fire could
start and you could be like look your
your ownership of combustibles is a
threat to my home there you could and I
think that's why you have an argument I
don't I'm not saying it's absolute but
I'm thinking any given thing that has a
a pro
a realistic possibility of having Mass
killing I think you can have an argument
to decide is this the thing sure that is
where do we draw the line right gotta
amend the Constitution I think you could
I think you could have the argument
without amending Constitution that's
what I'm saying I think you could but
then that's basically stating that the
Constitution doesn't matter no I mean
free speech is not free speech if I
threaten you that's not free speech
right so there are some we have to draw
a line on what's a threat well we draw a
line on that same thing right but
keeping and saying I'm gonna go do
something from so like speech is is is
somewhat nebulous in that in that
respect but there are people who are
phrase speech absolutists that say sure
speech is not action and I'm not that
I'm not I think if you're actively
threatening people and you're making
people feel like you're actually going
to hurt them or kill them that to me is
in free speech particularly if you're
someone who is physically in some way
smaller or what the case may be I think
there is a point where you go yeah
that's that's not no threatening is this
is not it's not an answer I disagree
because as uh right now we have a large
political fashion in this country that
says words are violence even if you
don't actually threaten them you could
say something like I think X group is
bad and they'll say that was a threat
that's violence and you're making me
unsafe so what not allowed to say that
that's what that's exactly where they're
going yes and that's a cultural issue
right and I think we have to change the
culture but this is why we have a
constitution to be a barrier against
these dramatic changes that if you want
to change it you got to change the
Constitution I think in instruction and
incitement to violence is not free
speech and why you just said absolutist
now I'm not an absolutist okay uh uh on
because I my my view is the the first
amendment is has some um
it it can be a bit nebulous in certain
respects what is Free Speech what is the
intent what is the right to the Press
it's about self-expression specifically
the right to keep in bear arms is about
defending the country from threats
foreign and domestic and arms back then
literally were warships sure that means
Canon grape shot
um Mana War frigates privateers corsairs
so if you if if we're it's not it's not
necessarily about the view of the
founding fathers because technology
changes it's about what was the goal of
Defending people's right to speech it
wasn't to defend you to go up to someone
and scream in their face and threaten
them it wasn't it wasn't their intent it
but uh you know for you to instruct
people on committing crimes
it was their intent to offend what was
the right to keep in bear arms it was
there and the founding father's intent
for you to have the same capabilities as
government in terms of warfare so that
you could both Aid and resist uh you
could you could Aid the government times
of War should we be invaded and you
could resist the invasions or tyranny
but let me go once further then all
right so you're saying I could own a
warship then okay nuclear weapons but
I'm by going back then warship what if I
were to take that warship and park it
outside your uh home that happens to be
on the coast point the uh cannon at your
home
and then start yelling I'm gonna blow
your home to pieces I'm gonna blow your
home to pieces and I just start yelling
that for I don't know me and my boys
yell for weeks on end but it's simple
you say Hey you the the the the the I
mean they don't they didn't have police
back then now police forces came around
shortly after I think late 1700s so
likely what you would get is people just
generally being like get your [ __ ] stop
don't do that shut up but what could
they really do but do nothing what they
could do but do you and your own mind do
you still think that is free speech do
you think that is well I don't think the
First Amendment the first amendment is
basically about your right to expression
sure your religion the Press it's not
about you threatening people yep or uh
so that's why I'm saying there are
people who believe it covers everything
right I I don't think that was that was
the intent the intent was that you could
meet at a local bar and talk about how
you think the government is tyrannical
right and that you couldn't be arrested
for doing so
now uh Second Amendment was literally
about keeping and bearing arms period I
understand the the quest to interpret
the First Amendment to better understand
what what we're doing with it and
there's a challenge there because you
know if you if you play that game of
threatening isn't allowed well then
people can change the definition of
threatening well the second second
amendment is mostly about defense it's
about defending yourself so what point
is the weapon used for offense and at
what point is offense a form of Defense
no no no no that's a horrible history of
War but the Romans and the Americans
basically invade so you don't get
invaded you never want to be on the
defensive that's wrong preemptive war is
wrong and if if you walk up someone and
punch him in the face out of fear they
were going to punch you you committed so
like a nuclear bomb is not a defensive
weapon so it's not so why would they
wouldn't be covered under the Second
Amendment of course I'm not sure that's
accurate I think nuclear weapons have
defended us against world war three
years but as a usage scenario it's used
to destroy areas not to protect yourself
but owning a nuclear weapon literally is
defense yeah and what do you think
like when the bolts are flying at you do
shoot the balls out of midair in slow
motion I do no no no no no a nuclear
weapon uh uh depending on its size can
take out a a military for fortification
or it can you know let's say a fleet of
warships are coming at you an open fire
you can take them out it's it's a weapon
your weapons are used for defense and
offense and in America if you buy a gun
and then use it as an offensive tool
against another person you go to prison
if you are minding your own business and
being a law-abiding citizen and someone
uses that gun against you and you defend
yourself with it you don't well actually
sometimes you do depending on New York
State you do that right sorry yes all
right all right well let's let's take
part of this let's we'll bring this
conversation over to uh timcast.com
member section we've got uh We've we've
got an interesting article about
policing
Austin cops being indicted I think this
is very very interesting so head over to
timcast.com sign up become a member to
help support all the work we're doing
and um we really appreciate it we're
gonna have that member segment up around
11 or so p.m smash like button subscribe
to the Channel all that stuff you can
follow us at timcastirl on Instagram
and I guess it's soon to be truth social
I don't know what's going on it's it's
really hard to sign up for yeah I hear
it's overloaded yeah oh yeah and uh you
can follow me at timcast on Instagram or
wherever else uh Larry you want to shout
anything out absolutely please head over
to larrysharp.com you can also Google
Larry sharp I'm an all the interweb
things I'm on Twitter and Facebook and
YouTube and all the things I'm even on
locals just but I'm on all the things
larrysharp.com audio slavery show up
please follow me sign up for my email
blast if you want to and if you want to
support you can always donate we even
take crypto oh
nice Chris carr17 on Twitter come check
out the feed yeah Ian Crossland hit me
up at Ian crossland.net really cool to
meet you man this is a great combo
looking forward to carrying it over to
the after show yep very enjoyable
libertarian talk without the libertarian
party which is what I always look for
when I talk about libertarian stuff you
guys may follow me on Twitter and
minds.com at Sarah patchlitz you
mentioned your website for donations
right yep okay larrysharp.com just want
to make sure we get that in there shot
with an e and the E stands for electable
right on we'll see you all over at
timcast.com for our members only podcast
thanks for hanging out bye guys